OKAY WITH THAT THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE WELCOME TO THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE HEARING FOR
ASSEMBLY BILLS IT'S GOOD TO BE
BACK IN THE BOTTLE BACK TO OUR
COMMITTEE PROCESS. I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN MAKING ME MANY PEOPLE WHO
WORK SO MAKE THIS HEARING POP
THANK YOU. WANTS TO THE COVE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IS
COVERING GUIDELINES. WE THOSE
ORDERS THIS HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH ONE OF OUR MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY- THE OF
THAT MEMBER IS CENTER GLAZER
MORNING SENATOR GLAZER. SAID
AGREES OR IF YOU A PERSON YOU
COULD YOU I DID BY THAT PERSON
NOW. THANK YOU AS CHAIR I DO
NOT HAVE THE APP NUMBER IN MY
OFFICE WITH ME WHERE I AM
CONDUCTING THIS HEARING. VERY
GOOD AND CAN YOU CAN YOU NAME
THAT STUFF. I NOT HAVE ONE I'M
SORRY. THE CHAIR NEEDS TO
ADJUST HER HEARING. THANK YOU
SENATOR GLAZER. CENTER GLAZER
AS A REMINDER PLEASE MEET YOUR
PHONE OR COMPUTER THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACUTE KHRISTICH FEEDBACK.
LASSITER TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT USE THE RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASK IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO. SELECT A NEW
BEFORE SPEAKING. OUR IT
PERSONNEL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE
WHEN YOU ARE DONE WHAT'S
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN. STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN YOU ARE READY TO THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS GIVE A MINUTE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TWO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT. TO
REQUIREMENTS. AND WE WILL USING
TELL THE SERVER FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO WISH TO TEST TO.
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
EVELYN AND SAID NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS ONE. FOUR
FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR AND THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
FIVE THREE. FOUR ZERO FOUR TWO.
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE AND OR COMMITTEE BY. WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DOUBT ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME PLEASE WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
SIGN LINE NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A
SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LONG NUMBER WELL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR I. NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW
RATE ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. THE
ARE YOU EARLY TO AVOID. YOU ALL
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU ARE
THE ON PRIOR TO GIVING TED OVER
THE PHONE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE OUR ROOM-
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THIS HERE I'M HEARING AT ITS
CUSTOMARY AND ME IN THE BILL
WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE. FOR HELP NEXT TO ME
TO. WELL EIGHT ONE HEARING HERE
IN AS CLOSE TO THE SAME MAN AS
IS CUSTOMARY THERE BE SOME LAG
TIME FOR TWO WHO ARE JUST TO
NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL IMPATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES. CAN BE
HEARD. GOOD NIGHT EMERGENCY HAS.
RESIDENT IT SITUATION LEADING
TO SIGNIFICANT DEMANDS ON OUR
STUDENTS OUR FAMILIES AND OUR
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS OUR
SCHOOLS AND CALL IT COLLEGES
ARE IMPACTED IN TERMS OF BOTH
PERSONNEL AND BUDGETS. DURING
THE DIRE SITUATION IN WHICH
MANY STUDENTS SCHOOLS AND
COLLEGES FIND THEMSELVES I'VE
ASKED ASSEMBLYMEMBERS TO POWER
DOWN THEIR BILL PACKAGES TO
INCLUDE ONLY BILLS THAT ADDRESS
THE MOST IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES.
AND DO NOT OUT OF
RESPONSIBILITIES COSTS AS A
RESULT WE WILL HEAR FAR FEWER
BILLS THAT WOULD UNDER NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES. I DEEPLY
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY FOR A-
THERE WELL BUILT ON THE TODAY
SIX OF THOSE BILLS ARE ON
CONSENT. FOR WE BEGIN OUR
PRESENTATION BILLS LET'S
ESTABLISH A CORE QUORUM.
CONSULTANTPLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AND LEYVA HERE. LEYVA
HERE WILK. WILK HERE CHIANG.
THE RUSSELL THE RISE OF HERE.
GLAZER SENATOR GLAZER HERE
GLAZER HERE MCGUIRE. PAN HERE
AND HERE THE CAR THANK YOU
MA'AM CONSULTANT A QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED MEMBERS I'M
GONNA REMIND YOU WHEN YOU SPEAK
IN YOUR MICROPHONE EVEN IF
YOU'RE JUST VOTING AYE ON THE
BILL PLEASE TURN IT OFF WE CAN
HEAR YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S BEGIN
WITH. AUTHOR OR MCCARTY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PROMPTNESS AND
BEING YOU'RE RIGHT ON TOP WE
ATE AT ALL. PARTY WILL. AB ONE
TWO THREE PLEASE. THANK YOU A
MADAM. AND MEMBERS SENATORS UP
FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO THINK
THAT YOUR STAFF YOUR CHIEF
CONSULTANT. WORKING WITH US IN
MY EXACT EXPECTING THE CAN
SUGGEST MEN'S EXCELLENT THANK
YOU. THE BILL FOR A COUPLE
YEARS AGO MORE AND THIS IS A-
TOOL FOR ALL BILL. WITH THE
FINANCIAL ISSUES THEN CERTAINLY
WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR
BREAKS DOWN EARLY IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL WAS PUT
ON POSSIBLE REALIZE. WOULD NOT
TEAM THERE'S OTHER ISSUES AT.
WRITERS OKAY SO. WE QUIT. AND
FOCUSED ON THE BILL HOW IT GETS
THREE. STATE AND CHILDCARE
SYSTEM TO HELP PROVIDE MORE
FOR. A WE KNOW THE EARLY AGE
MATTER SO CHRIS DURING A
CHILD'S YEARS IS BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT BUT ALSO- FOCUSES
ON ISSUES LIKE- FEDERAL ENERGY
INTERGENERATIONAL POVERTY
MAKING SURE WE ADDRESS OUR OUR
SCHOOL. ACHIEVEMENT OCT YEAH
SURE WE- UP ISSUES THE KIDS THE
CRIMINAL THIS. SO WE KNOW EARLY
EDUCATION MATTERS BUT WE AGAIN
WE DO KNOW THAT SOME OF THESE
PROVIDERS ARE FACING SOME
CHALLENGES SO WHAT WE HAVE
BEFORE US TODAY IS A- IT WOULD
HELP REDUCE PAPER. AND THE
MEASURE BURDEN FAMILIES AND
ROLLING. IN A CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM AND
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE. AS WELL
AS OFFERING PROVIDERS GREATER
FLEXIBILITY IN TRANSFERRING
FUNDS BETWEEN CONTRACTS USING
RESERVES TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF CHILDREN TODAY LASTLY THE
THIRD ELEMENT IS WAITING FAMILY
FEES FOR THOSE WHO ARE
RECEIVING DISK. RATHER IN
PERSON. AGAIN THANK YOU I FOR
YOUR AYE OF THE SMALL WITH ME.
EARLY AS CALIFORNIA AND
STOCKTON CO KATANGA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO SUPPORT AND ANYONE
WANTING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT I
THINK WE HAVE OF A- LOZANO ON
THE PHONE AND ALSO SCOTT MORE.
GOOD MORNING- CAROLINE IN THE
VAN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS BUT THE SAID THE FINAL
ON AND THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF EARLY AT CALIFORNIA. A
LONGSTANDING POLICY IN
ADVOCATES CANONIZATION
DEDICATED TO IMPROVING ACCESS.
POLITY OF CARE FOR KIDS IN
CALIFORNIA. EARLY AGES PROUD TO
CO SPONSOR AB ONE TWO THREE AS
A CRITICAL STEP TOWARD
STABILIZE THE EIGHT THIRTEEN
CARE SYSTEM WHILE SUPPORTING
WORKING FAMILIES IN A REALLY
REALLY DIFFICULT ENVIRONMENT.
WE HAVE ALWAYS NOW ARE PRETTY
LEARNING I'M AS A FOR CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES IT TURNS BUT THE
CURRENT HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
CRISIS DEMONSTRATE IT. AT CAN
FOR THEIR SOCIAL BUT A X. EVEN
MORE THE PANDEMIC HAVE SHOWN
HOW IMPORTANT IT INCLUDES ARTS
FOR OUR CHILDREN OUR FAMILIES
AND OUR PROVIDERS AB ONE TWO
THREE MAKES CRITICAL NEED A
PURPOSE TO IT SHE THIS ONE OF A
KIND. IT'S A THREE OFFERS IS
THE ABILITY PROVIDERS TO
MAXIMIZE RESOURCE SERVICE NEVER
AND THEN AFTER TO OPEN TO AB
ONE TWO THREE WE ALLOW
PROVIDERS TO USE FUNDS IN THERE
WE BEYOND WHAT CURRENTLY
MANDATED. ARE YOU MENTION
COMMITTED TO. WITH CALLED TO ME.
OUR MUCHO INTEREST TO PUT FAT
RESOURCE WHAT PROVIDE. THE THEY
NEED TO THE CRISIS. YOUR THREE
OFFERS NAY REMEDIES TO SOME THE
HARD PRESENTED BY THE THAT MAKE
AND MAKES ME CHANGES COULD SAVE.
THE FORTY THREE I RISK REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE ON A. B. ON TWO
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- THE NEXT IN SUPPORT
MISTER US GOT MORE ARE YOU ON
THE LINE. YES THANK THANK YOU
MADAM. AND SENATOR HI MY NAME
IT'S GOT MORE. THAN THE- BANGO
WE ARE THE LARGEST RETOOL CAL
PROVIDER IN THE BAY AREA.
HELPING SENT THOUSANDS OF LOW
INCOME CHILDREN ON A PATH TO
THRIVE. IN KINDERGARTEN AND
LIGHT HER CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
LIKE OUT THE CROP THE STATE.
THIS PANDEMIC HAS BROUGHT
SIGNIFICANT DISRUPTIONS RISING
COSTS. AND DRAMATIC CHALLENGES
FACING OUR FAMILY AND THAT.
WE'RE PROUD THAT WE NOW HAVE
ALL FIFTY TWO OF ARTS CENTER WE
RE OPENED. WITH A FEELING
CENTERED APPROACH. IT IS CLEAR
THAT THE NEXT YEAR WILL
CONTINUE TO REQUIRE US TO BE
RESPONSIVE. AND FLEXIBLE AB ONE
TWO THREE WILL HELP US DO
EXACTLY THAT BY PROVIDING NEW
TOOLS THE BILL USED TO BETTER
MEET THE NEEDS. OF OUR FAMILIES
AND CHILDREN AB ONE TWO THREE
MAKES IT EASIER FOR FAMILIES TO
ENROLL AND THOUGHT THAT I CHILD.
BY ENDING ORACLE. THE FAMILIES
WHO ARE ROLE IN MEDICARE OR
THING THE FOR THE FAMILY TO
GATHER INCOME. ADDITIONAL AND
UNNECESSARY PAPERWORK AND
REDUCING THE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN ON ENROLLMENT STAFF TO
VERIFY INCOME. AB ONE TWO CREEL
OUT PROVIDERS TO TRANSFER FUNDS
BETWEEN CHILD CARE AND STATE
PRESCHOOL CONTRACT. WITH THE
FINANCIAL TO ENSURE CONTINUITY
OF CARE FOR CHILDREN AND TO
MEET THE EVER CHANGING NEEDS
THE FAMILY. IN THE PANDEMIC AND
BEYOND. AB ONE THREE WILD
PROVIDERS THE WAY FAMILY COULD
BE. REALLY SOLD IN DISTANCE
LEARNING RIGHT NOW WE HAVE TO
COLLECT FAMILY BE. BERMAN BàN
EVEN IF THEY AREN'T RECEIVING
PERSON CARE WHICH WILL LIKELY
LEAD TO WIDESPREAD THIS
ENROLLMENT IN JEOPARDIZED FUN.
ALLOW PROVIDE TO CHOOSE THE WAY
THE FEES. I TRY BUNDLING OVER.
SURE CARE FOR THE LEARNING AB
ONE WHO CREATED THE STAFF
SUPPORT CHILDREN AND FAMILY
IT'S CARE. DURING THE COLD WITH
PANDEMIC AND THEN THE LAW TERM
AND WE RESPECTFULLY URGE AND
IPHONE THANK YOU. EXCELLENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
SHOULD SAY BEFORE WE BEGAN BOTH
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WILL HAVE
FOUR MINUTES TOTAL AND SUPPORT
WAS WELL UNDER THE FOUR MINUTES
SO NOW WE ARE GOING TO. MOVE TO
ANY WITNESSES THAT WE HAVE IN
TWO OR THREE. ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND FORTY TWO OH THREE
SAYING THEN WE WILL MOVE TO.
OUR REMOTE ROOM TWENTY FORTY
ANYONE AND TWENTY FORTY SEEN
NONE. AND NOW WE WILL MOVE TO
WITNESSES THAT ARE TESTIFYING
THROUGH OUR TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE. OUR MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF AB ONE TWO THREE
WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE TWO THREE. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
AND THE OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AND ONCE
AGAIN IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE TWO
THREE. PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND OUR FIRST COMMENT COMES
FROM MINE FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. A REBEKAH GONZALEZ
MASS ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND ONE
MOMENT FOR NEXT LINE. IN LINE
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME IS PATRICK
MARCH HEARING WITH COUNSEL FOR
A STRONG AMERICA WHICH
REPRESENTS OVER FIVE HUNDRED
LAW ENFORCEMENT LEADERS RETIRED
ADMIRALS AND GENERALS AND
BUSINESS LEADERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. AND I'M CALLING
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
ONE THREE TIMES YOU KNOW HIGH
QUALITY PRESCHOOL GIVES
CHILDREN THE SKILL THAT THEY
NEED JUST LET. ME BY NAME
ORGANIZATION AND IF YOU SUPPORT
THE BILL PLEASE. META MODERATED
WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE. ARE NOT AT THIS TIME
OKAY VERY GOOD WE ARE NOW GOING
TO MOVE. EXCUSE ME WERE NOW
GOING TO MOVE TO OPPOSITION.
AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE A WITNESS
ON AN OPPOSITION ZAHN LORE IF
YOU WERE ON THE LINE PLEASE Q.
IN. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN.
AT THIS IS A SOPHOMORE BUT THEY
CALIFORNIANS COMPLETE AT THE
STATION AT THE AT THE END OF
OUR PERCENT OF FOR FOUR
THOUSAND MEMBERS IN THE
EIGHTIES. PRESCHOOL PROGRAM THE
MAJORITY OF WHICH ARE
INSTRUCTIONAL. I LIKE TO
KNOWLEDGE AND THANK THE AUTHOR
AND HIS STAFF WORKING WITH THAT
ON COMPLEMENT TO THE SOUTH ARE
CONCERNED. MOMENT WE HAVE A AN
OFFICIAL OF HER LET THE A GOOD
CONDITION. THE BILL BE FOR THE-
THAT THAT THE CAMP. OF RESERVE
FUND FOR PROFESSIONAL. WE
RECOGNIZE THE DURING THE AND
MAKE AGENT SOMEBODY BUT THE- TO
I TRY THE UNIQUE CHALLENGES
THAT ARE. PRO MAY HAVE BUT WE
ALSO MONEY THAT ANY BUT THE
LADY IN HOW. THANK YOU ARE LOW
TO A TO THE CRY. AND THAT WE
ARE NOT MAKING LONG TERM POLICY
CHANGE THANK LEAD TO FUNDING
FOR TRAIN FOR OUR MEMBERS. THE
WE HAVE PROVIDE SUBJECT IS A
MEMBER THAT WOULD LIMIT AT IT'S
LIKE IT. WOULD BE SHE THE PLAN
THAT MAKE AND A LOT OF USE OF
THE FINE HE SPENT ON THING AS.
DISTANCE LEARNING THE- BAD IN
OTHER. PRIORITY AT THE ARE HAD
BEEN IS. WOULD BE IF ON MANY
ISSUES AND SO ARE OFF. THAT-BEACH REACH A CONSUL. THANK YOU
THIS OP. TO SPEAK WITH YOU THIS
MORNING. THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOU. OKAY WE'RE NOW
GOING TO LOOK FOR. THE BY BE IN
FORTY TWO OR THREE. SING AND
HEARING THEN WE'RE GOING MOVE
TO TWENTY FORTY. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO OUR TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MADAME MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE
UP PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION OF ONE
TWO THREE. THANK YOU AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF. AB
ONE TWO THREE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE
IS NOBODY IN Q. THANK YOU MADAM
OPERATOR WE'RE GOING TO BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO ANY DOES ANYONE HAVE
ANY COMMENTS QUESTIONS CONCERNS
I SEE DOCTOR PAM. GO AHEAD
DOCTOR PAM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR- A CENTER CARDIFF
AT PRE SHE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO WITH THE BILL BUT PERHAPS
CAN YOU- JUST ADDRESS WHAT THE
OPPOSITION CSEA THE ISSUE THAT
THEY RAISED A AND A FEW PLANTS
AND- ADDRESS THAT. YEAH THANK
YOU BOB THAT WE HAVE GREAT
RESPECT FOR THE SCA WORKING
WITH THEM ON OTHER EARLY
EDUCATION BILLS AND- THIS IS
THE LATEST WHO THEY CAN OR
ATTENTION WE WERE UNABLE TO
ADDRESS BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
HOPEFULLY WILL. GO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH WITH WITH THEM- I THINK
IT'S NOT INSURMOUNTABLE SO
THANK YOU. APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU VERY GOOD. OF CENTER
GLAZER I DO NOT SEE YOU WITH
YOUR HAND UP SO WE WILL
CONTINUE HERE ANYONE ELSE. OR
DO WE HAVE A MOTION. SO THANK
YOU THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR TO RAZA. THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
EXCUSE ME AS SOMEONE PARTY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I'M
GOOD THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB ONE TWENTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR LEYVA AYE. AYE WILK HI
WILK I CHIANG. CHIANG AYE
DORADO. RUSSELL AYE GLAZER. I
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE CAN I CAN I.
VERY GOOD THAT BILL. WE WILL
LEAVE ON CALL FOR US TO MCCAIN
TO THANK YOU ASSEMBLY AND THANK
YOU AGAIN BEING ON TIME.
ALRIGHT OUR NEXT AUTHOR IS I AM
GOING TO PRESENT FOR DR WEBBER
SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE THAT TO
THE INTO THE AGENDA BUT I DON'T
SEE ANY OTHER OFFERS HERE. SO
ONE OF THE CONCERT. THREE THAT
WOULD HAVE MISTER VICE CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHAT A
GREAT IDEA. ALRIGHT LET ME GET
TO MY CONSENT CALENDAR
INFORMATION. OKAY ON SENT TODAY
WE HAVE ITEM EIGHT AB TWENTY
ONE TWENTY SIX ITEM TEN AB
THIRTY ONE THIRTY SEVEN. ITEM
ELEVEN AB THIRTY THREE SEVENTY
FOUR CONSENT AS AMENDED ITEM
TWO AB NINE AWAIT ITEM THREE AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY. ITEM FIVE AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE DO WE HAVE
A MOTION- REMOTE SO MOVED A
MOTION TO ACCEPT THE CONSENT
ORDER HAS BEEN. MOVE BY. I'M
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL ALL
CONSENT CALENDAR SENATOR LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE WILK HI WILK I
CHIANG CHENG I. DORADO TO
RUSSELL AYE GLAZER. I LASER I
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN HI AND I
ALRIGHT WE WILL ALSO LEAVE THAT
ON CALL SO THAT SENATOR MCGUIRE
CAN VOTE. ALL RIGHT WE NEED
AUTHORS BUT SINCE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY LET'S GET STARTED OKAY. I
AT. ONE THIRTY. I HAVE
RESTORING THE- IN ORDER. JUST.
SHE. YEAH WE WANT TO GET YES-
I'M PRESENTING. FOUR SEVEN
MEMBER GABRIEL OKAY VERY GOOD
IF. THERE'S WILL GO TO YOU WILL
HAVE PERFECT AND. RIGHT RIGHT
UP NEXT. IS ITEM NUMBER FOUR A.
B. EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE FIVE
DOCTOR WEBER AND PRESENTING-
FOR TODAY WILL BE OUR CHAIR-
SENATOR LEYVA. WITH THAT. YOU
MAY PROCEED VERY GOOD THANK YOU
SENATOR WILK- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM
PRESENTING AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
FIVE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
FIVE WILL REQUIRE LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES TO IDENTIFY
UNSPENT SUPPLEMENTAL AND
CONCENTRATION GRANT FUNDS FROM
THE PREVIOUS CHEAPER AND USE
USER FUNDS THOSE ABOUT FIVE.
FOR THE- OUTCOMES OF THE
INTENDED STUDENT GROUPS. UNDER
THE L. C. F. F. CONCENTRATION
AND SUPPLEMENTAL GRANTS ARE
AIMED AT PROVIDING ADDITION
RESOURCE. FOR DISTRICTS TO HELP
LEARNERS LOW INCOME STUDENTS
FOSTER YOUTH THESE FUNDS WERE
NEVER MEANT TO BE GENERALLY
ALLOCATED THIS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING CAME WITH THE PROMISE
OF ACCOUNTABILITY OVERSIGHT.
CINCINNATI L. C. F. F. THESE
GRANT PROGRAMS HAVE PAID OUT
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS TO SCHOOL
BUT THE PROMISED LAND ABILITY
NEVER MATERIALIZED. LAST YEAR
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WEBER AND FOR.
REQUEST OUR SUPPORT TRANSFER
BEINGS AND THEREFORE THE STATE
OF THE ART OFF CHIU TO ON THREE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CLOVIS OAKLAND
AND SAN DIEGO UNFORTUNATELY THE
HONOR AND HER TEAM OF
INVESTIGATORS CONFIRMED WHAT
WAS PRETTY FEARS. FOUND THAT
SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAD THEIR
UNSPENT SUPPLEMENTAL AND OR
CONCENTRATION FUNDS AS PART OF
THERE'S DISTRICTS GENERAL FUND
THE FOLLOWING YEAR SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN SAN DIEGO
CLOVIS AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HELLO HOW OLD HUNDRED AND
TWENTY POINT SIX MILLION FOR
MENTAL AND CONCENTRATION FUNDS
INTO THEIR BASE FUNDS. BECAUSE
WE FELT IT WE HAVE GIVEN SCHOOL
DOES A PERVERSE INCENTIVE TO
IGNORE THE NEEDS OF OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS AND
APPROPRIATE THOSE FUNDS FOR
OTHER PURPOSES. THIS LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY PERPETRATES A
SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS BLACK BROWN
LOW INCOME ENGLISH LEARNERS AND
STUDENTS IN FOSTER CARE TO FALL
BEHIND THE REST OF THEIR
CLASSMATES. IN THE AFTERMATH OF
COVERT NINETEEN CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS WILL BE FACING A
LEARNING LOS UNLIKE ANYTHING
WE'VE EVER SEEN AND OUR STATE.
FUNDS ALLOCATED TO LOW
PERFORMING STUDENTS SHOULD
RETAIN THEIR DESIGNATION IN
GOOD AND BAD TIMES. THIS WILL
BE EVEN MORE IMPORTANT POST
CODE NINETEEN WOULD STUDENTS
WILL PROBABLY FALL EVEN FURTHER
BEHIND WITHOUT THE FULL MEASURE
OF THESE RESOURCES. AND THE
STATE WERE ONLY THIRTY ONE
POINT 3% OF BLACK STUDENTS AND
THIRTY SEVEN POINT 3% OF LATINO
STUDENTS. MEET STANDARDS IN
ENGLISH IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
THE SUPPLEMENTAL AND
CONCENTRATION FUNDS MEANT TO
ASSIST THE STUDENTS RETAINED
THEIR DESIGNATION. AB EIGHTEEN
THIRTY FIVE WILL PROVIDE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY NECESSARY TO
PROTECT THE CRITICAL
EDUCATIONAL SUPPORT OF THESE
FUNDS. ABILITY MATTERS TO THE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN
IN THIS STATE WHO ARE NOT
GETTING THE EDUCATION THAT THEY
NEED OR DESERVE. ON BEHALF OF
DOCTOR WEBER I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR FIVE OF. THANK YOU
SIR LABOR. IT THIS TIME WE WILL
HEAR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I
BELIEVE ON THE PHONE WE SHOULD
HAVE TWO PEOPLE A JESSE WELCOME
WE TEACH PLUS. THE MAN TRAN
WITH CHILDREN NOW A MODERATOR.
GOOD MORNING KELLY VAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS JACKIE WELCOME I AM
A THIRD GRADE TEACHER ON TOP
AND ENERGY EIGHT AND WHAT
CONTRA COSTA UNIFIED ENERGY TO
PLUG CALIFORNIA POLICY FELLOW.
I AM HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE. NEARLY
90% OF THE STUDENTS AT MY
SCHOOL ARE IDENTIFIED AS
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED AND
ON THE TOP FOR ENGLISH LEARNERS
I KNOW FIRST HAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AND DEPORTED DEALT TO
MEET MY STUDENTS UNIQUE MEAN.
THANK YOU JUST ACROSS THE
COUNTRY I TAUGHT REMOTELY ALL.
UNLIKE THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT WE WILL BE
OUT AGAIN. PULLED UP NEXT MONTH.
EVEN THOUGH I GOT TO SEE MY
STUDENTS FACES LIGHT UP EVERY
DAY DURING ONLINE CLASS MùT
TEACHING. NEVER PAUL DIDN'T.
AND WE'VE SEEN OF THE HARDSHIP
FALL DOES ON THE HIGHEST NEED
STUDENT I THINKING ABOUT THOSE
IN MY WHO DIDN'T HAVE A ACT
WHEN THE AND MY NEW COMERS
STUDENT WHO IN SCHOOL TO PORT
BACK IN JANUARY THE MOST. WITH
IN YOUR- THE BUDGET DEFICIT.
HER CONDITION AN INCREASE SIZE
AMONG OTHER IN EVEN BEFORE THE
CALL THE NINETEEN RELATED COSTS
MY DISTRICT AND OTHERS ARE THE
ALREADY TAPPED TO MAKE I THE
STATE AUDITOR FOUND IN HER
COURT DISTRICT CAN TREAT ANY ON
BANK THE FINAL AND
CONCENTRATION IN ANY GIVEN YEAR
BASED ON THE FOLLOWING YEAR AND
CAN USE THEM FOR. THAT IN MORE
THAN EVER WE MUST ENSURE THE
INTENDED FOR D. VAN GROUPS
ISSUED. ACTUALLY THE CURRENT
LOCAL DUE TO COVER ARE EFFECT
ALL AND ALL. BUT WE THAT THE
HIGHEST NEEDED IN WILL BE. AND
AT THE STATE HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO WHAT IT
CAN TO ENSURE THAT THE MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS ARE NOT
FURTHER DISADVANTAGED WHEN POOL
THREE OF. I'LL BE A- SURE THAT
LIAISON THE BILL IN HOW THEY
CHOOSE TO SPEND THE SIGNED.
WHAT SHOULD NOT BE FLEXIBLE IS
THAT THESE FINE TO REACH THE
STUDENT THEY WERE INTENDED FOR.
I URGE THE STATE LEGISLATURE TO
PASS EIGHTY EIGHTEEN THIRTY
FIVE TO ENSURE THAT FUNDS
INTENDED FOR DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS. ARE YOU STILL GROUP
FOR THAT. I DIDN'T GET ABOARD
PRESS TO WAIT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT
TESTIMONY NOW WE SHOULD HAVE OF
SAMANTHA TRAN. GOOD MORNING-
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MATHIS TRANSAMERICA SENDING
CHILDREN NOW AS WELL AS MY
FELLOW COULD SPONSORED
EDUCATION TRUST WEST AND TEACH
CLASS- WE ARE GRATEFUL TO THE
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBER. STAFF
WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE EIGHTY EIGHTEEN THIRTY
FIVE TODAY. IN ORDER TO HELP
INSURE THAT READERS WILL CALL
IN THE OFFICE. LAW IT'S CLOSE.
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF. WHICH
IS TO PANDEMIC IN THE TICKET
LEARNING LAW THE CARD ACROSS.
THE LIKELY AFTER EXISTING
ACHIEVING AT. AS A COMEDIAN.
NOTED COURTESY EITHER FOUND.
DISTRICT ARE USING ON THAT
AMOUNT. DOLLARS INTENDED TO
HELP THE AT EIGHT. NO I EIGHTY
EIGHT THIRTY FIVE IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY THE
DISTRICT COMMUNITIES RESOURCES
TO ADDRESS BUDGET FLEXIBLE OKAY
COMPETITION DOLLARS IS NOT THE
ANSWER FIRST WE ARE PLEASED
THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR PROTECTED EDUCATION
FUNDING IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
AND PROVIDED ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDING TO HELP ADDRESS. AND I
DELETED EXPENSES SECOND.
FUNDING IS ALREADY FLEXIBLE IN
FACT IT CAN BE USED IN IN
NUMBER WAYS THEY FROM LOCAL
FRESH ALL THE DIFFERENT IS THAT
IT USED TO PRINT THE BENEFIT
CALIFORNIA LOCAL. CHILDREN
EITHER THE VERY FEW WHO WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED- BY
THE GLOBAL PANDEMIC THEY-
STRUGGLE TO MAKE ENDS MEET WHO
ARE FLUENT IN ENGLISH AND FACE
THE BEAST TROUT. BECAUSE
EXTRAORDINARY FOR. THE DEPEND
BILL BE NO LOCAL ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR THE TWENTY TWO TWENTY ONE
SCHOOL YEAR. WITH LAW HE FINING.
DATA WILL BE A TIME WHEN WILL
BE FACING. PRESSURES AND
DIFFICULT. WILL BE WILL BE MADE
THAT HAVE WAXING. THANK YOU.
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT ARE
FURTHER BEHIND IT IS CRITICAL.
AT THIS MOMENT IN TIME AND
GARNER VOLATILE STUDENTS NEED A
HIGHER LEVEL OF SERVICE. THAT
THE STATE MAKE IT CRYSTAL CLEAR
THAT FUNDING FOR HIGH NEED TO
WHAT SHOULD BE THE BENEFIT THEM
AND I LIKE HELPING TO MAKE THE
WHOLE. IT IS. CHARLIE ENCOURAGE
DRIVE EIGHTY THIRTY THANK YOU.
THE YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AT
THIS WE WILL GO TO A PEOPLE
THAT ARE IN SUPPORT HE WOULDN'T
BE SIMPLY ADDING ALSO BE- YOUR
NAME NAME OF YOUR ORGANIZATION
AND THAT YOU SUPPOT THE BILL
WE WILL OPEN IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE. NINE I HAVE WE COULD
I TAKE A LOOK AT ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. NO ONE THERE SURPRISE AT
THIS POINT- WILL TURN OVER TO
MODERATOR MODERATORS OR ANYBODY
IN THE QUEUE TO. VOICE SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL. ABSOLUTELY AND
AS A REMINDER PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO TO COMMENT AND
SUPPORT AND OUR FIRST LINE IS
NINE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND SENATOR PAMELA GIVE
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU. AT NINE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ON BEHALF OF THE INVOICE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AT NINE
FIFTY SIX LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
JUSTIN HIGHER ON BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANKS
FOR TIME. THANK YOU. AND NINE
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
HARRY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AT NINE THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHRIS ALL
GET OFF HALF OF LOS ANGELES
CITY MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU. AT
NINE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY SAYS THERE ARE THOSE
WITH YEAH REPRESENTING-
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL FOR ALL THE REASONS GIVEN.
THANK YOU. IN LINE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING ALICE KESSLER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOL ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND
ONE THREE THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES A MEMBER OF THE
EQUITY COALITION IN SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE. THANK
YOU. IN LINE FIFTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS CHERYL
WILLIS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
TEACH PLUS CALIFORNIA HOW
COSPONSOR AND SUPPORTER OF AB
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. THE NINE
FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
JOHN AT THE MAIN GATE ON BEHALF
OF ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVING OF
THE DATA IN THE COURT. THANK
YOU. TEN NINE SIXTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
GOOD MORNING THIS IS PATRICK OR
TEAR WITH COUNSEL FOR A STRONG
AMERICA IN MARIN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THE MIND FIFTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING DAVID NEVIN ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND NINE
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CARLOS MACHADO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. IN LINE THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ANIMALS ARE CALLING
ON BEHALF OF INVENTED PROJECT
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORTER
SB THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND NINE SIXTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS BRIAN
RIVAS ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST- PROUD CO
SPONSOR IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
IN Q. THERE THANK YOU MISS
MODERATOR AT THIS POINT WE WILL
TURN TO THE OPPOSITION AND I
BELIEVE WE HAVE IN THE QUEUE
AND I'M SORRY I DO NOT DOUBT
PRONOUNCES SO LAST NAME SERRA.
PATCHES BUT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS. DISPATCHERS ARE YOU
ON THE LINE. WHEN MY LIFE ON
THE LINE. GOOD MORNING THE
MORNING MORNING. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THERE
ARE BUTTONS THAT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS UNFORTUNATELY IN
OPPOSITION. IN THE- I AM BLACK
COMMITMENT TO SERVE OUR JUST
STUDENTS AS INTENDED BY THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
OUR CONCERNS ARE WITH A MYOPIC
APPROACH OF EIGHTY EIGHTEEN
THIRTY FIVE THAT DOESN'T
RECOGNIZE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED SIGNIFICANT REFORMS TO
LOCAL CONTROL AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN AS PART OF
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN FORTY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. WE ARE THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION TO UPDATE
THE AL CAPP TEMPLATE BY OKAY
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY THIS YEAR
TO ENHANCE TRANSPARENCY AROUND
HELP FUNDS ARE USED TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF STUDENTS PRIORITIZING
ACTIONS BUDGET ALLOCATION. WITH
A FOCUS ON STUDENT OUTCOMES
MENU TEMPLATE ALSO REQUIRES AT
LEAST IDENTIFY WITHIN THEIR
ANNUAL UPDATE ALL SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN. AND IT
THAT ACTION IN A DAY TO MATURE
DIFFERENT BETWEEN THOSE PLANS
AND THE ACTUAL EXPENDITURES
THIS REQUIREMENT WELL THEN I
WILL DEMONSTRATE WHETHER AULIE
IMPLEMENTS THE ACTIONS OF
STEADY WOULD AND IT'S NOT
REQUIRED. BY NATION FROM ITS
DEPARTURE WE BELIEVE THAT THE
NEW TEMPLATE WHICH WAS THAT IF
I STAKEHOLDERS WOULD ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS RAISED BY SOMEONE
NUMBER WEBER HOWEVER THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE STATE BUDGET
SUSPENDS THE USE. OF THE NEW IN
RECOGNITION GLOBAL PANDEMIC
BECAUSE A COLD NINETY. EIGHTY
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE
UNFORTUNATELY WALKS AWAY FROM
THE LCS ABSTRACT STRUCTURE.
SERVICES RETURNS OUT OF ORACLE
BUT APPROACH THAT LENDS ITSELF
TO MOVE AWAY FOR FOCUSING ON
STOOD SERVICE BASED ON THEIR
NEW. WHICH CREATES A HE
CHALLENGES OF SCHOOL JUST FROM
TO DOUBLE STRAIGHT TO CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP AND THESE
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES IN ORDER TO
IMPROVE STUDENT OUTCOMES WE
NEED DEDICATED AND SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING AND ABILITY TO USE A
DATA TEMPLATE ALREADY VETED BY.
FOR MAKING FURTHER ADJUSTMENTS
IN AN ENVIRONMENT UPGRADE
FISCAL AND HEALTH LIKE
UNCERTAINTY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY
AT THIS POINT- WE WILL MOVE TO
THOSE IN OPPOSITION THAT ARE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE. SEEING
NONE- IF WE COULD HAVE MOVED TO
ROOM AT TWENTY FORTY. AGAIN AND
NO ONE PRESENT SO AT THIS
POINT- MISS MODERATOR IF YOU
CAN CHECK TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE I WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TO
THE BILL. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHTEEN
THIRTY FIVE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. ONE EIGHT
THREE FIVE. PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS IN Q. A RIGHT THANK
YOU MISS MODERATOR SO AT THIS
POINT WE WILL PULL IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS AND CONCERNS AND WE
WILL OPEN WITH A SENATOR GLAZER.
KISSES HIM I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. IT WAS A
SOLID WITH THE FARM OKAY. A
LITTLE CONFUSION ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER. ANYONE
ELSE ON THE COMMITTEE WELL THE-
OKAY BUT SEEING AS SAYING NO
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
SENATOR ALSO HAS MOVED THE BILL.
AND WITH THAT OF THE
CONSULTANT- I GUESS WE'D LIKE
TO CHAIR TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I HAVE A- WITH THAT.
THIS CALL THE ROLL. ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB ONE EIGHT THREE FIVE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR LEYVA HI
LEYVA I WILL HI WILK HI CHANG.
CHANG I DORADO AYE RUSSELL I
GLAZER. BY GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE
PAN HI AN BY. SIX ONE. AND
WE'RE AT ABOUT SIX OH AND LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR CENTER- MCGUIRE TO
ADD ON. CONGRATULATIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR WILK
APPRECIATE YOUR HELP IN THIS
PROCESS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER SIX AB NINETEEN
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. TODAY PRESENT A. B.
NINETEEN THIRTY FIRST I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL AND I
ACCEPT THEIR CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS THESE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THE PROCESSOR TIKI IN
THE BILL AND WILL BE TRIGGERED
IF. ADMISSIONS PALATABILITY
REQUIREMENTS ARE PROPOSED
RATHER THAN IT IS AN EXISTING
REQUIREMENT IS ALTERED THESE
AMENDMENTS HELP EASE SOME OF
THE CONCERNS THAT CSU EXPRESSED
IN THIS BILL. THE NINETEEN
THIRTY WILLING IS THE OVERSIGHT
THE PUBLIC UNIVERSITY'S
ADMISSION AN ELIGIBILITY
POLICIES TO ENSURE THE POLICY
CHANGES- EQUITABLE AND DO NOT
HAVE NEGATIVE OR UNINTENDED
IMPACTS. ON UNDER REPRESENTED
STUDENT POPULATIONS. LAST YEAR
THE CSU PROPOSED A NEW
QUANTITATIVE REASONING
ADMISSIONS ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENT FOR FRESHMAN
APPLICANTS. THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
REQUIRE FUTURE INCOMING
FRESHMEN AT CSU. THAT PROPOSAL
WOULD HAVE REQUIRED OF FUTURE
INCOMING FRESHMEN AT CSU TO
COMPLETE AN ADDITIONAL YEAR OF
QUANTITATIVE REASONING. THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS
VOICE MANY CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL AND THE IMPACT THAT IT
COULD HAVE ON UNDER REPRESENTED
STUDENTS. WELL THE CSU
ULTIMATELY DECIDED TO DELAY THE
VOTE ON THIS PROPOSAL AND TO
TAKE FURTHER STEPS TO EVALUATE
ITS IMPACT IT UNDERSCORED THE
NEED TO DEVELOP A CLEAR AND
TRANSPARENT PROCESS FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS TO
FOLLOW WHEN CONSIDERING THE
ADOPTION OF NEW ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS. FOR PROPOSALS
WITH STAKES THIS HIGH MORE TIME
AND EVALUATION IS NEEDED PRIOR
TO READING REACHING A DECISION.
AB NINETEEN THIRTY WILL ENSURE
THAT ADMISSION ELIGIBILITY POP
POLICY DECISIONS ARE ONE MORE
TRANSPARENT. HOW PROPER
OVERSIGHT AND IMPACT
ASSESSMENTS AND INCLUDE-COORDINATED IMPLEMENTATION
PLANS WITH PUBLIC ELEMENTARY
AND SECONDARY EDUCATION SYSTEMS.
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT OUR
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES REMAIN
ENGINES OF ECONOMIC MOBILITY
FOR UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS
AND NOT INCREASE BARRIERS TO
ACCESS. AB NINETEEN THIRTY IS
AN IMPORTANT OVERSIGHT
NECESSARY TO ENSURING AN
EQUITABLE AND FAIR ADMISSIONS
PROCESS. ON THE PHONE TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS KATRINA
LINDEN OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY AND MANY
RODRIGUEZ OF EDUCATION TRUST
WEST. VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE WILL GO
TO YOUR LEAD WITNESSES- IT
SOUNDS LIKE SINCE YOU
INTRODUCED KATRINA FIRST THAT
WILL HAVE HER GO FIRST KATRINA
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR LEVINE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO TRAIL AND THEN
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS MANAGER AT
THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY. STATEWIDE POLICY
RESEARCH ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED ENSURING THE OCT
BRING IN. COULD YOU CHECK TEN
CREATE A COLLEGE I WOULD LIKE
TO RECORD THE UNPRECEDENTED
TIME YOUR HAND AND THANK YOU
OFFER YOUR LEADERSHIP. DURING
THE TIME WE ARE MIND AT THAT
CALIFORNIA'S RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
GEN INTERDEPENDENT. I THINK THE
ECONOMY DEMAND MORE COLLEGE
GRADUATE AND DIDN'T NEED THE
SUPPORT OF THE STATE ACCESS OUR
RENOWNED PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION THEM THANK YOU SEE
LIKE TO GET THEIR. HE CUTTING
HER UP BETWEEN. CRITICAL EIGHT
STRENGTH AND WILL BE TOWARD THE
COVERING THE PANDEMIC. MY
CHANGES TO ELIGIBILITY TRACTOR
NEVER BELIEVE POINT LEVEL
ENGAGED. AB NINETEEN THIRTY
RECOGNIZING THAT THE DEMOCRATS
BY THE STATE PM MANY MORE
THOUGHT HE AND INCLUDED THAT.
WHEN AND HOW YOU NEVER
CONSIDERING ALLERGY
REQUIREMENTS. IF THEY HAVE AN
INTEREST IN A THAT FOUND HIRED
IN. WITHOUT A FAIR EQUITABLE
EMISSIONS. THE PUBLIC ALSO
DEMAND THAT AND DEMAND THAT ARE
TO SYSTEM WELCOME ACUTE TROUT
THE THEM AND PROCESS. SHE YOU
ARE AWARE OF RECENT. YES WHEN
YOU SEE HAVE TAKE A OVER THE
YEAR. YOU CAN A PROPOSED
CHANGES EACH OTHER OWN MANY
ALLAH WERE. PROFESSIONAL
ADMISSION. UNFORTUNATELY AKITA
ONE OF THE PROCESS HI ALLOW
TRUMP. AND APPROACH CONFLICT.
WITH CRITICAL STAKEHOLDERS THAT
WOULD BE IMPACTED BY THE CHANGE
INCLUDING. TWELVE TO COMMUTERS.
AND STAKEHOLDERS POLICYMAKERS
AND- HOW THE IMPACT OF THE
STUDENTS ABILITY TO COULD YOU
THE COLLEGE. THEY SHOULD BE
MADE WITHIN THE CONFINES OF ONE
INSTITUTION AND WITHOUT FOR
CONSIDERATION OF HOW THE
UNIVERSE YOU'RE RIGHT THAT THAT
VISION WHAT OTHER OPTIONS
BECAUSE THAT. AND THE POTENTIAL
IMPACT OF THE CHANGE. YEAH MOST
PART OF BIRTH AND THE VALLEY BE
HER. FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS
ARE LIGHT AND BY MADE OF
AMERICAN AND SOUTH. ASIAN YET
BECAUSE FOR THE- HURT. THE
ANSWER MUST BE NO AND WE MUST
ENSURE A COSS WHICH I THOUGHT
ACCURATE NOW. YET THE CALLED
EARLIER THIS YEAR THE CRITIC TO
AND UNDER. WHO WOULD BE COUPLE.
AND BUT WASN'T UNTIL A STUDY
INDEPENDENT COMMIT BY THE
EDUCATE ABBOTT. INCLUDE
CAMPAIGN WHICH FOR AND CONFIRM
THAT YOU THOUGHT LIKE ME TO THE
BRUNT OF THE PRINTER. CHANGE I
HAVE BEEN GIVEN FROM NORTH HERE
AT CENTRAL AND SOUTH LOOKING
BACK. AND THAT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED WITHIN THE CON OF
THAT. PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES ARE
THE BY NUMBER ALL AND ONE THAN
EVER BE ON OTHER CRITICAL IN
INCREASE IN VALUE ADDED AND IN
OUR STATE WITHOUT MY TIRES
CORNER BODY TO FACILITATE COULD
INTO MENTAL. LIKE THIS BECAUSE
CAMPING COMBAT UPON A- TWO INCH
ALL BECAUSE HE AN INCREASE
ACROSS UNDERTAKEN MONKEY THESE
CHANGES. AB NINETEEN THIRTY AT
SOUTH CREEK. THE HOUSE YEAH THE
WHEN YOU SEE CAN ADOPTING
IMPLEMENT ELIGE REQUIREMENTS
pON ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS
AND MEANS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I RESPECT. URGE YOUR
AYE. THANK YOU. MISTER
RODRIGUEZ WE GOING TO MOVE YOU
MISSILE G. USE ALMOST ALL OF
THE TIME. SO YOU HAVE A HELP
SIX. LEFT OF PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE A- AUSTIN. GOOD
MORNING SHARE LOW COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MANY OF THE GET IT ON
THE APP THAT YOU CAN TRUST. ALL
TRACK A LOT OF COMMENTS ON
PARTNERS FROM. COLLEGE UP TO
JUST MAKE JUST ADD THAT THE PER.
OF INCLUSIVE TRY. CORD AND
EQUITY MUCH AUTHENTICALLY OUR
TWELVE AND STAKEHOLDERS WILL BE
HOW WE AND- UNDER ELIGIBILITY
CHANGE. IN THE FUTURE. IN THE
PROPOSAL. WITHOUT DIGNITY. IT
FROM THE STATE AND THIS BILL
NOT REPEAT THAT STAKE THE NEED
TO CENTER EQUITY IN POLICY.
THAT WILL DIRECTLY CONSCIOUS
UNDER SERVED IN UNDER WRAPS CAN
YOU HAS ONLY BEEN BACK TO FIVE
THE TEN DAY MAKE AND CIVIL
RIGHTS WILL INTO WHERE PEOPLE
ARE NOT ONLY TO MANY OF YET
PEOPLE BUT INTENT COULD. POLICY
MAY ON HOUSES TO ARE OR ARE NOT
CERTAIN THAT SHE BE NINETEEN
THIRTY SURE ANY FUTURE DO NOT
THEIR JOB APPROVAL OUR BEST
FIRST AND THAT THE GUARD BUT SO
OF US HAVE DEMANDED IN THE PAST
WITH THAT I WAS ASK YOUR AB.
THE SIR MEMBERS WE GOING TO THE
TWO OR THREE HERE AND IF WE
HAVE. POOR. FORTY THE LET'S GO
TO OUR TOLD LAW MADAM OUR
MODERATOR HIS QUEUE UP THOSE
AND SO. THANK YOU AND IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF.
AB NINETEEN THIRTY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME AND
OUR FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM
MINE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS REBECCA THEM BOTH
FOR THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
AND NINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM SO ON SOME OF
THOSE SO WHAT I'M GOING HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONLINE
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LNE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY VALLEY KINCAID WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AND NINE SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
CARLENE CARTER ON BEHALF THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND QUIRK. THANK YOU.
AND NINE SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. THE NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. OKAY
AND IF I MAY HAVE YOU REPEAT
YOUR NAME THAT WAS MISSED. A
QUALITY HELLO HELLO GOOD AND
WITH WIDENING GROUP
REPRESENTING ACTION
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. AND THEN
NINE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN I HAVE. SELECT YOUR ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM MODERATOR THIRTY
THANK YOU WELL WE'RE GOING TO
GO NOW TO LEAD OPPOSITION-
MARQUITA GRIN NOTE SHARE ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. I AM GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
MARCADO CORNELL SHIRE I SERVICE
THE ASSISTANT VICE CHANCELLOR
OF EDUCATOR PREPARATION AND
PUBLIC SCHOOL PROGRAM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
BEFORE I BEGIN WITH LIKE. BUT
CASE. WE BELIEVE OUR GOAL AND
MISSION ARE ALIGNED AND THAT WE
BOTH. WANT TO ENSURE ALL
STUDENTS HAVE ACT TO HIGHER.
ESPECIALLY THOSE STUDENTS FROM
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AS YOU
THE CSU THE MOST DIVERSE FOUR
YEAR PUBLIC UNIVERSITY SYSTEM
IN THE NATION. THE CSU IS ALSO
ONE OF THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
INSTITUTIONS WITH THE STUDENT
BODY THAT IS THE MOST
ETHNICALLY ECONOMICALLY AND
ACADEMICALLY DIVERSE IN THE
NATION. THIS IS NOT BY ACCIDENT
IT IS OUR MISSION. BUT CSU
STRIVES TO CREATE A WELCOMING
ENVIRONMENT WHICH PLACES
EMPHASIS ON STUDENT SUCCESS.
THIS IS EVIDENT BY THE FACT
THAT THE CITY PROVIDES MORE
THAN HALF OF ALL UNDERGRADUATE
DEGREES EARNED BY CALIFORNIA'S
LATINO AFRICAN AMERICAN AND
NATIVE AMERICAN STUDENTS.
NEARLY ONE THIRD OF
UNDERGRADUATES ARE THE FIRST
AND THEIR FAMILIES TO ATTEND
COLLEGE. THESE PERCENTAGES
ILLUSTRATE THE LONGSTANDING
WORK OF CSU ADMINISTRATORS
FACULTY AND STAFF TO ENSURE OUR
STUDENTS RECEIVE A QUALITY
EDUCATION MATCH WITH
OPPORTUNITY. AGAIN WE BELIEVE
THE CSU AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA ARE ALIGNED IN OUR GOALS
AND MISSION. WE DIFFER HOWEVER
ON THE IDEA THAT. IS SIMPLY
BILL NINETEEN THIRTY PROVIDES
ABOUT. OR ADD TO ACROSS. WHICH
IS ALL BEEN ADOPTED BY THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY. AS
A PRINCIPAL CONTRIBUTOR TO THE
QUANTITATIVE REASONING PROPOSAL
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE QUANTITATIVE
REASONING IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
OCCURRED OVER TIME. AND WAS
STAKEHOLDER INPUT. AND IT IS
BECAUSE OF THE STAKEHOLDER
INPUT THAT THE IMPLEMENTATION
PLAN WAS REVISED ON MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS AND EVENTUALLY BECAME
WHAT IT IS TODAY. IT IS THIS
PROCESS OF COOPERATION
COMMUNICATION AND TRANSPARENCY
THEIR RESULTED IN A PHASED
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN. THE PLACES
STUDENT ACCESS AND SUCCESS AT
THE HEART OF THE PROPOSAL. AS A
REMINDER THE IMPLEMENTATION
PLAN CONSISTS OF A TWO YEAR
PERIOD TO THE VALUE WAIT AND
STUDY THE IMPACTS OF CHANGING
THE ISSUE ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS. SECOND THE GOALS
RESENT A FINAL RECOMMENDATION
TO THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES IN THE
SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
AND THIRD THE NEW REQUIREMENTS
WOULD NOT GO INTO A FACT INTO
THE FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN
TO ALLOW FOR SUFFICIENT
TRANSITION TIME. AS WE EVALUATE
THE PROCEDURES CONTAINED IN
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN THIRTY
WE RECOGNIZE SEVERAL
SIMILARITIES TO THE CSU
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN INCLUDING.
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY TO THE
SAID MIDDLE OF ANNUAL REPORT.
AN EXTERNAL REVIEW BY A
NONPARTISAN RESEARCH
ORGANIZATION TO INFORM THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND THE EFFECTS
OF THE PROPOSED CHANGE. THE
CREATION OF A COMMITTEE TO
PROVIDE GUIDANCE AND ENSURE THE
PLAN PUT FORTH IS EQUITABLE AND
AVOID ANY UNINTENDED IMPACTS
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS. AND
THAT THE COMMITTEE WOULD BE
MADE UP OF MULTIPLE
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING STATE
AND LOCAL OFFICIALS K. TWELVE
DISTRICT PERSONNEL STUDENTS AND
FACULTY AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT WHAT
DIFFERENCE. BUT CSU WILL BE
CONVENING ITS COMMITTEE BEFORE
THE BOARD APPROVED THE
RECOMMENDATION AND NOT AFTER
THAT'S REPOSE AND ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN THIRTY IN FACT THE CSU
QUANTITATIVE REASONING
COMMITTEE IS MEETING ON AUGUST
ELEVENTH. THE PURPOSE OF THE
CSU QUANTITATIVE REASONING
STARING THE IS TO INFORM.
GUIDANCE AND DEVELOP AND
MONITOR METRICS TO ASSESS THE
IMPACTS AND EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE PROPOSED CHANGES
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS. THE
CSU QUANTITATIVE REASONING STIR
STEERING COMMITTEE IS COMPOSED
OF THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR OF
EDUCATIONAL POLICY. THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION. THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE EDUCATION ADVISER.
RESIDENTS OF THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION. BUT CHAIR OF THE CSU
ACADEMIC SENATE. THE CHIEF
ACADEMIC OFFICER OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE. I
CSU STUDENT REPRESENTATIVE A
PUBLIC SCHOOL DISTRICT STATE
SUPERINTENDENT IF YOU COULD
WRAP BUT I'M PLEASE ACTIVE
DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION TRUSTS
LAST. WE UNDERSTAND THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS WITH YOU'VE
YEARS ARE ALL ALL OF YOUR TIME
AND THEN SUMMER WRAP UP PLEASE.
OKAY OUT FOR- WE DON'T BELIEVE
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN THIRTY
ADDS VALUE ARE BENEFITS TO THE
CSU AND FOR THESE REASONS WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY
WE'RE GOING TO LOOK FOR
OPPOSITION- HERE IN THE ROOM
AND FORTY TWO OH THREE SEEING
AND HEARING NONE WHAT TWENTY
FORTY. SEEING THAT THERE LET'S
GO TO THE PHONES TELEPHONICALLY
MADAME. MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
NINETEEN THIRTY PLEASE. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF A. B. NINETEEN THIRTY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF A. B.
NINETEEN THIRTY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. THERE WE HAVE NO ONE
IN K<c.cyan>. OKAY THANK YOU VERY</c>
MUCH WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU AND
WITHIN A THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD- I DID HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT THE PROVISIONS
REGARDING AFTER- ADOPTIONS
THERE'S IMPLEMENTATION
COMMITTEE- I UNDERSTAND AND-
DISPOSE OF I IN IN YOUR
PROGRESS REPORT- DOES IT
BETWEEN THE PERIOD OF PROOF FOR
SUCH I CLEAR FIVE. THE UP
PROGRESS SUPPORT AFTER THE
CHANGE AND ELIGIBILITY POLICY
SO IS THERE. IS THIS SOMETHING
THEY'RE GOING TO ANNUALLY FOR
AND- AD INFINITUM- OR IS IT FOR
A FIXED PERIOD OF TIME I JUST
WASN'T CLEAR ON THAT AND THEN.
ALSO SO THE LORDS OF A YOU
GONNA BE STILL RECEIVING
REPORTS TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
YEARS LATER AFTER
IMPLEMENTATION OR WAS THAT THE
INTENT OR NOT AND THEN ALSO-
GIVEN THAT YOU KNOW POSSIBLY
THERE COULD BE MORE THAN ONE
CHANGE OVER TIME IS THERE
SOMETHING THAT SEPARATE
IMPLEMENTATION COMMITTEE THAT
REVIEWS EACH CHANGERS OF ONE
COMMITTEE THAT REVIEWS ALL THE
CHANGES ONE COULD. STOP CHANGE
ONE YEAR AND TEN YEARS LATER DR
JANE SO YOU CLARIFY THIS ISSUE
SELFISH IT. AFTER I HAVE ON THE-
YEAH. BUT I KNOW THAT IT'S
CERTAINLY WOULDN'T BE THE
INTENT OF THE BILL TO HAVE- YOU
KNOW- IMPLEMENTATION REPORTS
GOING OUT TWENTY FIVE YEARS
LATER I AT AT WITH THE BILL.
ADDRESSES IS WHAT HAPPENED AND
THAT IS THAT- EVEN THOUGH THE
LEGISLATURE HAD HEARINGS ON THE
TOPIC WERE WE HEARD FROM- THE-
CIVIL RIGHTS GROUPS UP AND DOWN
THE STATE. AND WE WERE HEARING
FROM SCHOOL DISTRICTS- AND I
BELIEVE ALSO THE-
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION- THERE WAS NO
RESPONSE THERE WAS NO RESPONSE
FROM CSU- AND IT WAS ONLY.
AFTER A I INTRODUCED THE BILL
THAT I THINK THAT WE GOT A
RESPONSE. AND SO WITH THE BILL
AGAIN TRIES TO DO IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT SEE ISSUE- INTERACTS
AND I. AGREE WITH THE CSU
PRESENTER- THAT I AM IN LINE
WITH THEM ON ON THEIR GOAL I
SEE HOW WELL THEY DO- AND-
UPWARD MOBILITY TO STUDENTS BUT
WHAT I DID NOT SEE. WAS
INTERACTION. WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE
LEGISLATURE SOME OF THE BILL
AGAIN TRIES TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
EIGHTY THANK YOU SENATOR PAN
OUR NEXT UP WE HAVE SENATOR
GLAZER CENTER GLAZER ONE WAY
FOR YOU TO APPEAR ON THE SCREEN
ALL RIGHT WE SEE YOU PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU AT CHAIR
LEYVA LET ME PERSIST EXPRESSED
BY APPRECIATE TO YOU ABOUT OF
CHAIR FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PARTICIPATE. REMOTELY HAD TO
THE COMMITTEES AS WELL SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT. I HAD A COUPLE
QUESTIONS I WANTED ASKED THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THIS
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY. TO
SPEAK TO THE ISSUE OF THE
PROCESS AND THE TRANSPARENCY OF
THE PROCESS THEY WENT THROUGH.
PRIOR TO THE- DISCUSSION AND
BOAT THEY TOOK OUT THIS PAST
JANUARY. THE QUESTION WAS TO ME
CENTER. IT WAS A CO FOR CENTER
GLAZERS BIG THE QUESTION WAS
FOR THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
GREAT MY SON. SHE WENT THROUGH
HIS CORNER SHIRE ARE USED ON
THE PHONE. I AM THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION SENATOR GLAZER-
AS YOU MAY RECALL THAT SHE IS
YOU HAS BEEN ENGAGED IN THE
CONSULTATION PROCESS FOR
APPROXIMATELY FOUR YEARS- WE
BEGAN TO WORK WITH OUR-
STATEWIDE ACADEMIC SENATE. AND
WE ENGAGED A NUMBER OF K.
TWELVE- CONSTITUENTS IN AS WE
DEVELOP THE PROPOSAL- OF THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES MINUTES- CAN
BE PROVIDED AGAIN. SO THAT YOU
CAN SEE THE WIDE VARIETY. OF
LOCAL AND STATE DISTRICT AND
COUNTY- OF REPRESENTATIVES AS
WELL AS A WIDE VARIETY OF
COMMUNITY BASED GROUPS THAT WE
INTERACTED WITH ON AN ONGOING
BASIS. AND SO. WE FEEL VERY
COMFORTABLE THAT THE
CONSULTATION PROCESS. PROVIDED
US WITH THE WIDE VARIETY OF
INPUT FROM ALL OF THESE MEMBERS
AS WELL AS OUR OWN STUDENTS
THAT LED TO THE CURRENT
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN- THAT WILL
TAKE EFFECT OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS. AND COULD YOU
ALSO SPEAK TO THE INDEPENDENT.
THIRD PARTY ANALYSIS THAT THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES HAS AGREED TO
UNDERTAKE AS PART OF THEIR
PROPOSAL. I CAN SO WE ARE
CURRENTLY- IN CONVERSATION WITH
A NONPARTISAN- RESEARCH
ORGANIZATION- TO- DEVELOP. CON
IF YOU WILL TO HELP US INFORMED
THE IMPLEMENTATION PLAN OVER
THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS- I AM
NOT READY AT THIS POINT IN TIME
TO IDENTIFY THAT NONPARTISAN
GROUP BUT WE HAVE BEEN AND
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM OVER
THE SUMMER MONTHS. AND COULD
YOU SPEAK TO THE AND THE
PRESENT THE COMPLETION OF THE
INDEPENDENT THIRD PARTY THE
TIME LINE FOR THAT. AND AT HOW
AND THE- THAT WILL- WILL BE IN
EFFECT OR NOT IN EFFECT IN
TERMS OF PRESENTING THE
FINDINGS. AND TO WHOM DOES IT
GO TO THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
AS A GO TO THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES WHAT'S THE PROCESS
FOR. THE DISCLOSURE OF THAT
INDEPENDENT THIRD PARTY
ANALYSIS AND FINALLY CAN YOU
PUT THAT IN THE CONTEXT OF ANY
FUTURE DECISION BY THE BOARD AS
TO WHETHER THEY WANT TO CARRY
OUT. OUR THIS SEVEN YEAR FACED
AN IMPLEMENTATION PLAN. YES AS
I MENTIONED- WE HAVE TO REPORT
TO OUR BOARD OF TRUSTEES BY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THE REPORT
BY THE NONPARTISAN RESEARCH
ORGANIZATION- WILL BE GIVEN TO
THE QUANTITATIVE REASONING
STEERING COMMITTEE AS I
MENTION. THIS QUANTITATIVE
REASONING STEERING COMMITTEE IS
COMPOSED OF A NUMBER OF
REPRESENTATIVES AND I'D BE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE THE ACTUAL
WHICH TO- THIS GROUP IF YOU SO
DESIRED. BUT THIS STATE
COMMITTEE. WILL TAKE THE FIND
DEAN'S- BUT- NONPARTISAN
RESEARCH ORGANIZATION TO HELP
INFORM THE REPORT THAT WILL BE
GIVEN TO OUR BOARD OF TRUSTEES
AND SPRING TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
PRIOR TO THE ACTUAL TITLE FIVE
CHANGE. AND SO IT IS ABOUT%
RECORD THAT IT'S PRESENTED AT
THE STEERING COMMITTEE THAT
WILL BE PRESENTED TO THE BOARD
OF TRUSTEES THERE WILL BE A
MATE IT WILL BE MADE AVAILABLE
PUBLICLY. VERY GOOD AND BAD I'M
SURE IF I COULD ADDRESS A
QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR YES
PLEASE PROCEED. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- ENGAGEMENT
AND PASSION ON THIS ISSUE OF
ELEGY AND ITS EFFECT ON ON
REPRESENTED STUDENTS I SHARE.
YOUR GOALS THAT YOU HAVE LAID
OUT OUR I AT THE THAT THE BOARD
OF TRUSTEES HAS ENACTED. A
SEVEN YEAR PHASE AND WITH
SEEMINGLY OFFRAMP STE TO
EXAMINE AN INDEPENDENT THIRD
PARTY ANALYSIS AND WHEN I LOOK
AT THE MEMBERSHIP OF THAT
COMMITTEE IT SEEMS LIKE THEY'RE
DOING EVERY THING. IS IN YOUR
BILL- THAT DID THAT THE SAME
CONCERNS THAT YOU HAVE REYES
WERE CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED
DURING THE DELIBERATION PROCESS
BY THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES. I WAS
A THOROUGH CONVERSATION DIVERT
THE UP MINUTES FROM THE JANUARY
MEETING EARLIER THIS YEAR WHERE
THEY ADOPTED THAT PHASED IN
APPROACH AND I'M I GUESS I'D
LIKE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT A AGAIN.
IF IT THEY SEEM TO BE A LAW
WITH THE CAN YOU PHRASE AND
PROCESS THAT YOU IDENTIFIED A-
AT A EIGHT INCLUSIVE GROUP TO
KIND OF DO THE EXAMINATION.
WHAT IS IT IN YOUR BILL THAT
DIFFERS AND I GUESS I'M LOOKING
FOR THAT CASE AGAIN ABOUT WHY
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD.
INTERVENE WHEN THEY SEEM TO BE
DOING EVERYTHING. THAT YOU WANT.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
CENTER GLAZER. AND I WOULD
AGREE THAT THIS ENDED WELL
THAT- THIS- EFFORT ON THE PART
OF CSU TO INTRODUCE. CHANGE THE
ENTRANCE REQUIREMENT OF ENDED
WELL ENDED WITH WITH WHAT WE
WANTED WAS WAS TO POSTPONE THAT
ARE OR OR TO GET RID OF THAT-
IF IT IF IT IS ONLY A
POSTPONEMENT BUT BUT WHAT WE
SAW WAS PROCESS OR OR LACK OF
THAT AND SO I THINK WITH THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL IS TO MAKE
SURE TO BE CERTAIN THAT THE
NEXT TIME NOT NOT FOR A
QUANTITATIVE REASONING BUT THE
NEXT TIME THAT THE CS YOU MAY
WANT TO ADD. ANOTHER FIREMAN IN
IN THE ENTRANCE REQUIREMENT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE NOT BE
LEFT OUT IN THE DISCUSSION AND
HEARD FROM C. ISSUE THAT THEY
HAD- MEETINGS WITH MANY
STAKEHOLDERS AND THAT IT WAS A
FOUR YEAR PROCESS BUT I CAN DO
THAT AT SIXTY FOR ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT WHERE I WAS TEACHER OF
RIVERSIDE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND A BOARD MEMBER OF
THE GROUP A UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SITE TO THERE THEY
WERE NOT A- THE- THEY WERE NOT.
ALTHOUGH UP TO THE POINT WHERE
TRUSTEES WE'RE GONNA A VOTE SO
AGAIN A SEVEN GLAZER FOR THE
LEADS. IS THAT THAT NOT HAPPEN
AGAIN. US BY THAT WOULD YOU
KNOW ASK THIS COMMITTEE- TO
VOTE IN FAVOR OF THE BILL. YOUR
LEYVA IF I CAN SPEAK THAT ON MY
OWN TIME YES PLEASE PROCEED.
WELL LET ME AGAIN THANK THE
AUTHOR HE'S A PASSIONATE
ADVOCATE FOR OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM VERY FEW IN
THE LEGISLATURE MATCHED. BY
HIS- GREAT LEADERSHIP ON A
HIGHER EDUCATION BATTERS AND I
SO APPRECIATE AT AND ADMIRE.
THAT LEADERSHIP. AND WHAT I'M
STRUGGLING WITH IS- YOU KNOW A
IT'S ALWAYS DIFFICULT- IN A
STATE AS LARGE AS CALIFORNIA. I
WITH MORE THAN A THOUSAND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. TO ENSURE
THAT EVERYBODY IS AT THE TABLE
HI EVERYBODY IS AWARE AND
INFORMED ITS CITY OF ITS
ONGOING CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE
WITHIN OUR OWN. LEGISLATIVE
BODY BATTERS THAT WE- CONSIDER.
UP BUT FOR ME IT SEEMS THAT THE
TRUSTEES. HAVE ENGAGED IN AN
OPEN TRANSPARENT WAY ON THIS
VERY DIFFICULT TOPIC. AND I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY MEMBER
OF THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES THAT
DIFFERS. WITH THE CONCERNS THAT
THE AUTHOR HAS RAISED ON THIS
PARTICULAR MATTER THAT OF UNDER
REPRESENTED STUDENTS AND
WHETHER OR NOT THIS NEW
REQUIREMENT WHICH- CREATES SOME
ELIGIBILITY CONCERNS I I'D I
THINK EVERYBODY'S ON THE SAME
PAGE. AND SO FOR ME WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THESE THESE
ISSUES I ALWAYS TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHETHER OR NOT. BUT
THERE'S A IT'S A COMPELLING
REASON FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
END INTERVENE. AT ESTABLISH NEW
LAW. BECAUSE OF WHAT REASONS
LACK OF RUST. LACK OF HONESTY-
BUT WE HAVE SET UP THIS BOARD
OF TRUSTEES TO DO OUR- POLICY.
WORK AND NOT FOR THE STATE
UNIVERSITIES WE IN THE SENATE.
REVIEW AND APPROVE EVERY.
GUBERNATORIAL NOMINEE TO THAT
BOARD AND IT GIVES US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE A BOARD THAT'S DIVERSE
AND- AND RESPECTED AND EDUCATED
TO DO THAT WORK OUR BEHALF SO
THAT'S THE SCREEN THAT I USE IN
LOOKING AT BILLS LIKE THIS WITH
THE BEST OF INTENTIONS BUT YET
INTERFERING IN A WAY THAT ISN'T
NECESSARILY JUSTIFIED AND
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S WHAT I
FEEL AND THIS PARTICULAR CASE
BUT IT'S NOT WITHOUT GREAT
RESPECT FOR THE AUTHOR. AND THE
GOOD WORK HE IS TRYING TO
ADVANCE YOUR TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER MEMBERS
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
YES SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH- ACTUALLY FIRST OF
ALL A QUESTION FOR HER A-
SUMMER VIDEO YOU DID MENTION
AND- YOUR- PRIOR TESTIMONY SAID
THAT YOU HEARD FROM CIVIL
RIGHTS GROUPS AND SOME OTHER
GROUPS THAT SAID THAT THEY
WEREN'T ENGAGED IN THE- THE-
DISCUSSION IS THIS PROPOSALS
BEING ROLLED OUT ITS YES YOU
ARE AT LEAST BEING PROPOSED. HE
LAB RATE ON THAT HURDLE THE
LOOK WHEN I HAD THE HEARING.
AND I DID HAVE A HEARING OF THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE- ON
ON THIS PROPOSAL. THERE WAS A
VERY LONG LIST SENATOR PAN. OF
CIVIL RIGHTS GROUPS OF FROM ALL
OF THE DIFFERENT- GROUPS. VERY
LENGTHY OF YOU KNOW ALL ALL
HAVING THE SAME CONCLUSION-
THAT- IT WILL THIS IS GONNA BE
SOMETHING THAT WAS DETRIMENTAL-
TO- STUDENTS OF COLOR. AND I
THINK THEY SHARED MY CONCERNS
THEY SHARED MY CONCERN OF THE
LACK OF INTERACTION AND SO. YOU
KNOW I KNOW I WAS CAUGHT BY
SURPRISE- WITH THIS MEASURE-
AND WHAT WAS STRIKING WAS THE
MOST STRIKING TO ME AGAIN WAS
THE LACK OF RESPONSE SO THAT
EVEN AFTER I HAD THAT HEARING
SENATOR PAN I WAS NEVER.
CONTACTED BY A CSU. AND I AND I
YOU KNOW I WON'T SPEAK FOR
OTHER OFFICIALS BUT I KNOW THEY
HAD THE- THE SAME- FEELING OKAY
YOU SO YOU ACTUALLY HEALTH AND
TERRIBLE AYE I WAS NOT
CONSULTED- EVEN AFTER I HAD THE
HEARING SO PERHAPS MAY I.
FOLLOW UP WITH A QUESTION TO
THE CSU REPRESENTATIVEYES
ABSOLUTELY- ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
THREE MS GREEN- SHERRY SO ON
THE LINE. I AM EXCELLENT DOCTOR
PAN HAS FAR DID NOT HEAR THE
QUESTION NO NO IT'S I HAD ASKED
THAT YET SO I DECIDED FIRST
FIND HAVE YOU SURE YOU'RE ON
THE LINE SAID THANK YOU THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE- SO. IF YOU NOTICE THAT
THE AUTHORS A NUMBER MEDINA WHO
CHAIRS THE HIGHER EDUCATION.
COMMITTEE AND THE STATE
ASSEMBLY. INDICATED THAT HE'S
THAT HE HEARD NOT ONLY FROM
PEOPLE BE ACTUALLY HOLD AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THIS
VERY TOPIC. AND DOES NOT-
ENGAGEMENT BY CSU. WHICH WOULD
BE VERY CONCERNING TO ME AS A
MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE CAN
YOU PERHAPS BE TO. THAT ISSUE I
MAY APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION AND- THE OUT REACH
THAT'S YES YOU DID AND
DEVELOPING- THE- THE WORKING ON
THE STANDARDS- CERTAINLY
RESPECT AND APPRECIATE- THAT-
YOU KNOW THE- ISSUES AROUND
DEAL ACADEMIC- FOR YOU. AND
THAT- SEE ISSUES- HAVE GETTING
SOME- YOU KNOW WE- WE ARE THE
FOR TO THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES IN
MANY WAYS IN TERMS THE
OPERATIONS OF CSU BUT I'M ALSO
CONCERNED THAT. EVEN HEARING
THAT THERE WAS FURTHER
ENGAGEMENT FROM C. IS SO I KNOW
IF IT TO WHAT HAPPENED- IN
TERMS OF ENGAGING THE CHAIR OF
HIGHER EDUCATION- AND IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND HE HAD MANY GROUPS
WHO CAME TO TESTIFY WHO SAID
THAT THEY WERE NINE GATES AS
WELL SO UNITED. I'M NOT SAYING
YOU TO REACH OUT TO THE RIGHT
STAKEHOLDERS HE SPEAK TO THE-
OUT REACH TO THAT STAKEHOLDERS
THAT. IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS
COMMUNITY AND- WHO ALSO PERHAPS
TO FIGHT AT THE- AT THE- OF THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR THAT-
QUESTION SENATOR PAN BUT SHE
ISSUE OF WAS REPRESENTED AT
THAT HEARING IN FACT I AND
SEVERAL MY COLLEAGUES-
PRESENTED THAT ON THAT DAY. AND
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT- WE HAVE
CONSULTED WITH A NUMBER OF
LEGISLATIVE STAFF TO DIFFERENT
LEGISLATORS- OVER THE LAST YEAR
AND A HALF. I DID NOT SPEAK
DIRECTLY TO- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA AND. I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT. BUT WE HAD MY COVERS.
WITH MANY DIFFERENT STAFF
MEMBERS DURING THE COURSE OF
THIS COMPLICATED PERIOD AND I'M
HAPPY TO PROVIDE AGAIN A LIST
OF- THE INDIVIDUALS AND THE
DATES AND THE TOPICS OF
DISCUSSION IF THAT WOULD PLEASE
THE COMMITTEE DID YOU
SPECIFICALLY REACH OUT TO CIVIL
RIGHTS GROUPS. IN THIS
DEVELOPMENT WE DID. YES WE DID
AND WE HAVE A NUMBER OF THOSE-
IDENTIFIED IN THE MINUTES OF
OUR BOARD OF TRUSTEES AND I'M
HAPPY AGAIN TO SHARE THAT. OKAY
BUT WE UNDERSTAND HOW CRITICAL
IT IS THAT WE WORK ALONG SIDE-
THE VARIOUS CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND WE ARE COMMITTED WITH DOWN
THAT. AND WE ARE COMMITTED TO
DOING THAT MOVING FORWARD. OKAY
I APPRECIATE THAT- WLL- I
GUESS WHAT I JUST SAY IS THAT-
I PREFER TO OUR DATA- CERTAINLY
YELL AT EIGHT I THINK THAT- WE-
KNOW WE WANT TO. AT RESPECT AND
PERHAPS EVEN THE FOR MANY CASES
TO THE TRUSTEES WHO YOU KNOW
ARE APPOINTED TO ADDRESS-
ISSUES AROUND AND INCLUDING
THINGS LIKE- ROMAN BUT I ALSO
KNOW IS A PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
THAT- STATE UNIVERSITY I AM
ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THE- THAT
DAY SOMEONE WHO EVEN CHAIRS THE
COMMITTEE ON HIGHER EDUCATION
IS HERE SAYING THAT THEY'RE
HAVING SOME CHALLENGES- TERMS
OF ENGAGING- AND- IS OFFERING A
BILL TO TRY TO ADDRESS SOME
DEFICIENCIES THAT. HE ISN'T
THAT A FIGHT IN THE PROP PERSON
DIED DO APPRECIATE THAT SEES
USE OF PARENTING MADE PERHAPS
MADE SOME CHANGES TO ADDRESS
THOSE BUT- I THINK THAT- I
THINK THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION AND ISSUE THAT TO.
CONTINUE THAT NEEDS TO MOVE
FORWARD AND- THIS UP WE TRY TO
DRESS UP THE ROLE OF OUR PA
UNIVERSE THEY YOU. THANK
SENATOR PAN THE SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I USE ONE
TO ADD THANK THANK THE AUTHOR
FIRST OF ALL. AND SECOND ADD TO
THE REASONS WHY THERE'S SUCH A
CONCERN ALL WHEN THIS ISSUE
CAME UP THE LATINO LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS SENT A LETTER. AND WE
GOT NO RESPONSE. AND I BELIEVE
THAT THE I BELIEVE THAT IT WAS
DONE EITHER A SEPARATELY WITH-
THE CAUCUS OR TOGETHER WITH THE
BLACK CAUCUS- BUT THAT. THAT IS
A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF. NOT
HAVING THE ATTENTION OF- YOU
KNOW OUR COMMUNITIES AND- IT
SEEMS TO ME IF THEY'RE ON TRACK
FOR DOING SOMETHING ALONG THESE
LINES THEN. THIS WOULD THIS IS
NOT GOING TO DETER THEM IN FACT
IT'LL JUST BE MAKE THEIR CASE
STRONGER FOR THE WAY THAT
THINGS SHOULD BE HANDLED THANK
YOU. THE CENTER DORADO MEMBERS
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER YOU MAY CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SIR DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR DORADO FOR MOVING THE
MOTION THE MOVING THE BILL THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB ONE NINE THREE
ZERO THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR LEYVA BY. THE AYE WILK.
WILK NOT VOTING CHIANG. CHIANG
I DORADO DORADO AYE GLAZER.
SENATOR GLAZER NOW GLAZER NO
MCGUIRE PAN ALL RIGHT CENTER
PAN ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU WERE
GOING TO LEAVE THAT BILL ON
CALL FOR SENATOR- ACQUIRED TO
VOTE SOME MAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU CENTER LIVE.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW MOVING ON TO
AB IN NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NECESSARY.
ASSEMBLY ONCE THE PODIUM IS
READY. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR. AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE WOULD
EXTEND THE SUNSET FROM JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
SIX FOR THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO UTILIZE A
BEST VALUE. EVALUATION AND
SELECTION PROCESS FOR PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS IN EXCESS OF A
MILLION DOLLARS THIS IS THE
PROCESS HAS ALLOWED LA U. S.
THE TO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
MULTIPLE FACTORS RATHER THAN
THE LOWEST. THIS CAUSED
PROBLEMS IN THE PAST SO IT
TAKES INTO CONSIDERATION. AMONG
OTHER THINGS SAFETY FINANCIAL
CONDITION. INSURANCE COVERAGE
CRIMES AND MISCONDUCT BONDING
SETTLEMENTS AND JUDGMENTS- WITH
ME I HAVE OLDER SHINE MOVE THE
LA UST. WHO WILL PROVIDE A
STATEMENT REMOTELY AS WELL
THANK YOU EXCELLENT THANK YOU
SIMPLY MEMBER- OLGA SHALLOW ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. I'M HERE GOOD
MORNING CHEN MEMBERS THE OLDER
SHALLOW WITH LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WE ARE
PLEASED TO BE THE FOUNDER OF AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE WHICH WILL
EXTEND THE SUNSET AUTHORIZATION
TO UTILIZE THAT VALUE
PROCUREMENT METHOD FOR BETA
VALUATION SELECTION LOCAL
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT ABOUT. ONE
MILLION DOLLARS OF THE PILOT
PROGRAM UNTIL TWO TWENTY SIX.
IN JANUARY TWENTY SIXTEEN BEST
VALUE WAS USED TO WORK FOURTEEN
CONTRACT TO SEVEN DIFFERENT
CONSTRUCTION COMPANIES.
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
HE'S PROJECTS AND THIRTEEN
SCHOOL CAMPUSES AND BENEFIT AND
ESTIMATE OF EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED STUDENTS. ALTHOUGH
BEST VALUE CONSCIOUS WORK MALL.
PERCENTAGE OF OVERALL NUMBER OF
COUNTRIES. FOR SIXTEEN THE
DOLLAR VALUE TO MY- A MORE
SIGNIFICANT AND MORE NINETY OF
ALL USE BECAUSE- COSTS. THE
PROJECT BENEFITS ON THE INITIAL
PILOT PROGRAM INCLUDING REDUCE
CONTENT DELAYED VIEW OR CHANGE
ORDERS UNLESS CLAIMS FROM
CONTRACTORS. ULTIMATELY
REDUCING COSTS THESE BENEFITS
YOUR REALIZE DALY ELLIE USE
THESE BEST VALUE. PROGRAM
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND STATE
AND LOCAL FUNDS BEING SPENT ON
SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION PROJECT
THAT LOS ANGELES UNIFIED. IT IS
IMPAIR IMPERATIVE THAT WE HAVE
THE NECESSARY TOOLS TO REDUCE
RISK AND MAXIMIZE EFFICIENCIES.
FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE
PLEASED TO SPONSOR AB EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR EYES
OUT. THANK YOU MS SHALLOW WE
WILL NOW GO TO SUPPORT HERE. IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE. SEEING NOT
LET'S GO TO TWENTY FOUR. SEEING
NONE LET'S GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINES- MADAME
MODERATOR IF YOU WILL HAVE
PEOPLE QUEUE UP FOR IN SUPPORT
OF NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN FAVOR OF AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN EIGHTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
ONE IN Q. IN FAVOR OF AB IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE VERY GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW GO
TO LEAD OPPOSITION WHICH I
THINK THERE IS NONE SO WE WILL
GO HERE TO FORTY TWO OR THREE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION HERE AND
FORTY TWO OF THREE. SEEING NONE
LET'S GO TO TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING NONE LET'S GO TO OUR
TELEPHONE LINES AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN- OPPOSITION
TO NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE MATTER
MODERATOR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF AB IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN.
OPPOSITION OF AB NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AND ONE MOMENT. WE HAVE
NO ONE IN Q. FOUR OPPOSITION
EXCELLENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE OF THE START WITH
VICE CHAIR WILK. BECKY MANAGER
ACTUALLY JUST HAVE A COMMENT I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR-BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD-
BEST VALUE IS A MUCH MORE
HOLISTIC A BETTER APPROACH THAN
LOWEST BID. HAVING SERVED YEARS
ON A COMMUNITY COLLEGE SHOULD
BORDER TRUSTEES. THE TWO WORDS
I HATED THE MOST WAS CHANGE
ORDER BECAUSE WE ARE FORCING
COULD WEAR FORCES TAKE THE
LOWEST BID AND THERE'S A LOT OF
TIMES WHERE WE DIDN'T THINK THE
BID WAS. WAS REASONABLE. WHAT
TIME ARE WE ABLE TO OVERTURN
SOMETHING SO THIS I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE. BETTER VALUE TO
THE TAXPAYERS AND- HIGHER
QUALITY PRODUCTS- FOR THE
STUDENTS SO WHY COMMITTEE FOR
THE BILL AND I WILL BE IN
SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU
SENATOR WELCOME MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED I SEE
NO HAND UP FOR CENTER GLAZER.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR PAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. RESPECT BEST FOREVER
THANK YOU SIR. ALL RIGHT SO WE
KNOW THAT'S- WE HAVE A MOTION
BOB DO CLASS TO THE FLOOR.
MADAM CONSULTANT HE'S CALL THE
ROLL. FILE NUMBER SET. AB ONE
NINE EIGHT ONE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE FLOOR SENATOR LEYVA
BY. HI WILK HI. WILK I CHIANG.
CHIANG AYE DORADO. THE RUSSELL
I'D GLAZER. SENATOR GLAZER HI
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN HI AND I
BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL SO
THAT SENATOR MCGUIRE CAN VOTE
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN HAVE
A GREAT REST OF THE DAY IF YOU
LIKE PLACE ALL RIGHT- WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO SENATOR TO ROSS
SO WHO IS GOING TO PER AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTEEN OR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL THIRD RUSSELL
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY YES
STAY RIGHT THERE PLEASE. OKAY
GREAT THANK YOU MEDI CARE AND
MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTEEN. THIS
BILL WILL REQUIRE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES TO CONSIDER.
HOMELESSNESS AS AN EXTEND
CIRCUMSTANCE WHEN THEY EVALUATE
APPEALS THIS IS IN THE APPEAL
PROCESS FOR THE LOSS OF
FINANCIAL LATE. COVERT NINETEEN
HAS EXACERBATED BOTH THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT STUDENTS WILL
STRUGGLE WITH ACADEMIC PROGRESS
AS WELL AS THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
THEY WILL EXPERIENCE HOMELESS.
WE ALL KNOW THAT ACTS TO FINE
AID IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
TO LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND
STUDENTS OF COLOR. SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS ANNUALLY A
NUMBER WHICH IS EXPECTED TO
INCREASE DUE TO THE PANDEMIC.
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTEEN WILL
MAKE IT MORE POSSIBLE FOR
STUDENTS WHO ARE STRUGGLING
WITH HOMELESSNESS TO RETAIN
THEIR FINANCIAL AID REMAIN AND
ROLLED. AND FULFILL THEIR
DREAM- IN THEIR DEGREE. THIS
BILL RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR AS WELL
AS IN THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE IS
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD COALITION
OF HOMELESSNESS EDUCATION AND
EQUITY ADVOCATES. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY IS DEBBIE RUSHER
FROM THE JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES
FOR YOUTH AND CODY VAN FILLED
IN A RECENT GRADUATE FROM
AMERICAN RIVER COLLEGE. THANK
IT'S A RAZA OKAY WITH IN
SUPPORT OF DEBBIE RAUSCHER ARE
YOU THERE. I AM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OF MY NAME IS DEBBIE
RUSHER AND I'M WITH JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR USE THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY. PRIOR TO THE COVER
NINETEEN CRISIS 19% OF STUDENTS
AT COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND 11%
OF CSU STUDENTS REPORTED
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. IN
THE FACE OF COVER NINETEEN AND
THE CONSEQUENT LOSS OF INCOME
FOR MANY COLLEGE STUDENTS THREE
HOMELESSNESS IS LIKELY TO RISE.
WHEN IS TO EXPERIENCE OF
HOMELESSNESS GRAY IT'S OFTEN
DROP IN MANY CONSEQUENTLY LOSE
ACCESS TO FINANCIAL AID BECAUSE
THEY FALL BELOW SATISFACTORY
ACADEMIC PROGRESS OR SAP
STANDARDS. WHILE MOST COLLEGES
OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAL
THE LOSSES FINANCIALLY DUE TO
SAP APPEALS PROCESS HE'S VERY
TREMENDOUSLY BY CAMPUS. WILL
QUALIFY AS A STUDENT FOR
REINSTATEMENT IS OFTEN BASED ON
THE PERSONAL PHILOSOPHY OF ANY
GIVEN FINANCIAL AID
ADMINISTRATOR. AND HOMELESSNESS
IS NOT CONSISTENTLY CONSIDERED
A VALID BASIS FOR APPEAL. SOON
TO EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS ARE
AMONG THE MOST DISADVANTAGED OF
CALIFORNIA'S COLLEGE STUDENTS
AND IN THE FACE OF THE CURRENT
CRISIS. THE STUDENTS SHOULD
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
BACK ON TRACK RATHER THAN THEIR
EXPERIENCE OF HOMELESSNESS
LEADING THE END OF THEIR
ACADEMIC CAREER. AB TWENTY FOUR
SIXTEEN WILL OFFER STUDENTS WHO
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS THIS
OPPORTUNITY. WILL HELP TO
MITIGATE THE EXACERBATION OF
EXISTING DISPARITIES WITHIN OUR
POST SECONDARY SYSTEMS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR CONSIDERATION
OF THE STILL. VERY MUCH NEXTEL
LEAD WITNESS IN SUPPORT CODY
BEEN FILLED AND CODY. GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME IS KERRY I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
TIME THIS MORNING I AM TWENTY
TWO YEARS OLD I ACTUALLY JUST
GRADUATED FROM CONSUMERS RIVER
COLLEGE AND STARTING AT TAX
STATEMENTS ALL. OF THE YOUTH I
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS I WAS
IN FOSTER CARE PLACEMENT AND
KICKED OUT AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN WITH NO WHERE TO GO
AFTER WORK. ALTHOUGH I WAS ABLE
TO CONTINUE MY ACADEMIC CAREER
IT WAS DIFFICULT BECAUSE WHEN I
WATCHED FINANCIAL AID
HOMELESSNESS ALONE WOULD NOT A
SUITABLE REASON FOR GETTING IT
BACK. FORCING ME TO SHARE
SPECIFIC TRAUMATIC EVENT IN
ORDER TO JUSTIFY REGAIN MY
FINANCIALLY. I WAS NOT READY TO
SHARE THIS INFORMATION LET
ALONE WITH STRANGERSAND IT
BECAME MORE TRAUMATIZING FOR
ME. I ALMOST LOST FINANCIALLY
DO NOT MEETING STOP.
REQUIREMENTS WHILE I WAS
HOMELESS. TING FINANCIALLY
WOULD HAVE MY- CAREER.
REGAINING MY AID ALLOW ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVE MYSELF
REQUIRED. MEETING THE
REQUIREMENTS ARE NOW MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT DURING THIS TIME WITH
OUR PANDEMIC COOLEY NINETEEN OF
BECAUSE MANY USE TO LOSE THEIR
SECURE HOUSING WORK HOURS AND
JOBS IN GENERAL. BECAUSE THE
NINETEENTH ALSO CAUSE
UNEXPECTED CHANGES THAT HAVE
MOVED THE MAJORITY OF CLASSES
ONLINE MANY STUDENTS INCLUDING
MYSELF STRUGGLE MORE WITH
ONLINE CLASSES WHICH CAN CAUSE
THE DROP IN GREAT. I GRADUATED
WITH HIGHEST HONORS THE ONLY
REASON THIS IS POSSIBLE.
BECAUSE I WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH
TO HAVE MY FINANCIAL AID APPEAL
APPROVED. WORDING AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTEEN IS IMPORTANT
ESPECIALLY IN TODAY' TIME
BECAUSE HOMELESSNESS HAVE
BECOME MORE OF A CRISIS THAN
EVER BEFORE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CODY. ARE WE ARE GOING TO
GO HERE TO FORTY TWO OR THREE
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE LET'S GO TO TWENTY
FORTY. SEEING NONE LET'S GO TO
OUR TELECONFERENCE LINES META
MODERATED TO HAVE ANYONE ON THE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY FOUR
SIXTEEN. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND OUR FIRST
COMMON COMES FROM THE LINE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING. ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT YEAH THANK YOU. AND
ONE FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. REBECCA
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
AT NINE FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
JOHNSON WITH THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND NINE SEVENTY
NINE NINE NINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MAIN GEAR AS
REPRESENTING THE FAN OF THE
EVER GROWING MANY CALLS
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
AND NINE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND ONE
MOMENT FOR LINE TWELVE BY
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TYLER ARE YOU ARE
ON BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN SUPPORT
EXCELLENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE YOU ARE NOW GOING TO
OPPOSITION I DON'T THINK I HAVE
ANY LEAD OPPOSITION SO WE'LL GO
HERE TO FORTY TWO OF. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE LET'S
GO TO TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NONE
LET'S GO TO OUR PHONE LINES
MATAMATA READER FEW COULD QUEUE
OF ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. TO
TWENTY FOUR SIXTEEN. AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTEEN PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTEEN PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE KNOWN IN
QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANYONE HAVE ANY. QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS. THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED US SENATOR GLAZER
DOES NOT HAVE HIS HAND UP. THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE CENTER TORONTO
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ARM. HEY
WANT TO CONGRATULATE ONE OF OUR
WITNESSES CODY BEN FELDMAN- FOR
SHARING WITH US WATER
EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN IN FOR
CARING. ABOUT OTHERS WHO CAN
FOLLOW BEHIND HER AND-
RESPECTFULLY ASK REVIVALS.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR PAN.
IT IS DO PASSED T APPROACH.
MAN CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ITEM NUMBER NINE. A. B.
TWO FOUR ONE SIX THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR LEYVA HI. I WILK HI
WILK I CHIANG. CHIANG I THE
RUSSELL I RUSSELL I GLAZER.
SENATOR GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE PAN HI AND I WILL PUT
THAT BILL ON CALL AS WELL ALL
RIGHT WE ARE DOWN TO OUR LAST
BILL AB NINE OH ONE SO WE'RE
JUST WAITING FOR THE AUTHOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO SEE IF WE
CAN TRACK DOWN SENATOR CLEAVER
GLOCK SKIS ME SENATOR MCGUIRE
SO THAT WE CAN LIFT THE CALL ON
BILLS WELFARE HE IS. SENATOR
MCGUIRE WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO
HAVE YOU WITH US TODAY. ALL
RIGHTS TO DELEGATE CONTROL ROOM
LIFT- THE MINUTE THE CALL ON
BILLS. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
MAN CONSULTANT A PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS FILE NUMBER
ONE AB ONE TWO THREE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. TO VOTING ON A
VICE CHAIR VOTING I SENATOR
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE HI WIRE I. VERY
GOOD THAT BILL IS OUT SEVEN
ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON O
BUY A FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR MEN
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER FOUR
AB ONE EIGHT THREE FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR VOTING ON
A VICE CHAIR VOTING I SENATOR
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE AYE
THE BILL IS ALSO OUT SEVEN
ZERO. REMOVED TO FILE ITEM SIX
PLEASE CALL THE OTHER MEMBERS.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB ONE NINE
THREE ZERO. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR VOTING I
VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING SENATOR
MCGUIRE REQUIRE I REQUIRE BY A
BLUE THE BILLS OUT FIVE ONE.
GOOD THANK YOU REMOVED A FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB ONE NINE EIGHT ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE FLOOR
SURE VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING
I SENATOR MCGUIRE REQUIRE I
REQUIRE HI THAT BILLS OUT SEVEN
ZERO. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER NINE
AB TWO FOUR ONE SIX THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING. VICE VOTING ICE
MCGUIRE REQUIRE A CLARIFY THAT
BE IS ALSO OUT SEVEN ZERO
EXCELLENT THE YOU YES CONSENT
YES WITH THE CONSECUTIVE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CONSENT
CALENDAR CHAIR VOTING ON MY-
CHAIR VOTING ICE MICHAEL.
REQUIRE I WHERE I SEC COUNTER
HAS BEEN REFERRED SEVEN ZERO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT
AND WE'RE JUST GOING TO WAIT.
FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON.
JUST
FOR CLARIFICATION OUR AUTHOR IS
ON HIS WAY WE HAVE GIVEN HIM
TEN MINUTES SO IF HE'S NOT HERE
BY- TEN FORTY EIGHT WE WILL
CLOSE THE HEARING SELF HANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
ALL
RIGHT- MEMBERS AND THOSE IN OUR
AUDIENCE AND TELEPHONICALLY
PARTICIPATING WE ARE GOING WE
TOOK A BRIEF PAUSE TO ALLOW.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON TO GET
HER TIME TO PRESENT HIS BILL.
HE IS NOT HERE BUT SENATOR PAN
HAS GRACIOUSLY- SAID THAT HE
WILL PRESENT THE BILL SO THIS
IS FILE ITEM TWELVE AB NINE OH
ONE SENATOR PAN PRESENTING FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON SENATOR
PAM. THANKS VERY MUCH AND GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS. WANTED THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SENT TO SPELL
BEHALF OF DECEMBER GIPSON TODAY
AND FOR THE COMMITTEE STAFFS
ENGAGEMENT IN DISCUSSIONS WITH.
THE SUMMER GIVE SINCE OFFICE
AND STAKEHOLDERS OVER THE PAST
YEAR. FOR THE EDUCATION- ONE
HERE THIS MORNING AND
MAINTENANCE TO THIS BILL WILL
BE TAKEN ON THE SENATE FLOOR.
AND THE PRESENTATION TODAY IS
BASED ON THAT VERSION. SO AB
NINE A ONE SIX ELIMINATE THE
PRACTICE OF VOLUNTARY PROBATION
AND WHICH CHILLED BUT NO WHICH
YOUTH ARE PASTE PLACED UNDER
PROBATION SUPERVISION FOR
BEHAVIORAL ISSUES. EVEN THOUGH
THEY HAVE NOT COMMITTED ANY
CRIME. UNDER VOLUNTARY PRO.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF YOUTH BOTH
COLOR ACROSS THE STATE ARE
SUBJECT TO TWO CONDITIONS THAT
ALLOW FOR RANDOM SEARCHES
CURFEWS SURPRISE HOME VISITS
DRUG TESTS AND INTERROGATIONS.
AGAIN THESE ARE YOUNG MEN AND
WOMEN WHO HAVE NOT ACTUALLY
COMMITTED A CRIME. ANY OF THEM
ALSO COME FROM FAMILIES WHO DO
NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES TO HIRE
AN ATTORNEY NOR DO THEY OFTEN
KNOW THEIR LEGAL RIGHTS. AS A
RESULT WITHOUT LEGAL
CONSULTATION THEIR PARENTS
ULTIMATELY FEEL COERCED TO HAVE
THEM PARTICIPATE. EIGHTY NINE
ONE TAKE TAKES MORE OF A
RESTORATIVE APPROACH BY
ENSURING THAT THERE ARE
LIMITATIONS AND SAFEGUARDS IN
PLACE WHEN REFERRING OR
PROVIDING YOUTH WITH SERVICES.
THIS APPROACH WELCOME TO
CONTINUOUS COLLABORATION
BETWEEN PROBATION LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES CAN BE BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND HEALTH
AGENCIES. IT ALSO AIMS TO
SUPPORT PROGRAMS TO PREVENT
YOUTH FROM ENTERING THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM ALL
TOGETHER. THE FIGHTING IN
SUPPORT TODAY IS CATHY SHARE
WITH THE ACLU AND SORRY- THOMAS
WITH THE USE JUSTICE COALITION.
SO. AND MORNING MADAM CHAIR
NUMBERS. OKAY OCTAVES CALDERON
BEHALF OF THE ACL L. YOU OF
CALIFORNIA CAN CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN YES WE CAN'T THANK
YOU. GREAT OKAY WE ARE PROUD TO
BE A CO SPONSOR OF AT EIGHTY
NINE NO ONE. THE ISSUES EIGHTY
NINE OH ONE ADDRESSES CAME TO
THE ATTETION OF THE ACLU IS
THE RESULT OF OUR WORK IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE AND TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN THE
PROBATIONDEPARTMENT IN
RIVERSIDE PLACED OVER THREE
THOUSAND YOUNG PEOPLE ON
PROBATION CONTRACT OUR NORMAL
YOUTHFUL BEHAVIOR. USING
WELFARE INSTITUTIONS SECTION
SIX FIFTY FOUR. YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE OFTEN REFERRED TO PROBATE
FOR VIOLATION OF WELL. YOU
SHOULD COACH. ASSEMBLY OR HEAD
THAT YOU REFER TO ALL THE-
IMPROPER AND- ALREADY. YOU ARE
PLAY ON PRO FOR CARD ABILITY.
OR DOES IN DISRUPT BEHAVIOR IN
ONE A STUDENT WAS PLACED ON
BUT- ON PROBATION BEHAVIOR
RELATED TO GRIEF FROM THE DEATH
OF BABY SISTER. ENFORCEMENT
FALLS DISPROPORTIONATELY ON
STUDENTS OF COLOR. YOUTH AND
THEIR PARENTS ARE OFTEN TOLD
THAT IF THEY DON'T AGREE TO
PROBATION THEIR CASES WILL BE
REFERRED TO THE A EVEN. HAS NO
CRIMINAL. VOLUNTARY PER PROBE
PROGRAM OFFER OPERATE WITH THE
OF THIS. THE JUDICIAL. SUCH AS
ADEQUATE NOTICE OF CHARGES OR
THE UNDERLYING FACTS OR ANY
KIND OF IMPARTIAL DECISION
MAKER. YET YOUTH BECOME SUBJECT
TO PROBATION TERMS INCLUDING
SEARCHES OF THEIR PERSONS AND
HOMES AS WELL AS RANDOM DRUG
TESTING. WE KNOW THIS KIND OF
PUNITIVE SURVEIL PROGRAM DOES
NOT WORK TO PREVENT. FUTURE
MISBEHAVIOR. ACCUSED OF SCHOOL
MAY. OR LOW LOW OFFENSES SHOULD
BE REFERRED TO APPROPRIATE
SERVICE PROVIDERS NOT TO
PROBATION EIGHTY NINE NO ONE
WILL ENSURE MORE EFFECTIVE AND
REPORTED OUTCOMES FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT LEAD WITNESS AND
SUPPORT PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS ARE YOU TIME I'M A HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT AND A MEMBER OF
THE YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION WE
ARE HONORED TO BE A CO SPONSOR
OF ASSEMBLY BILL NINE OH ONE
THAT WILL STOP THE PARTIES BY
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS ACROSS
THE STATE OF PUTTING YOU. WHO
HAVE NOT BEEN CHARGED WITH ANY
CRIME UNDER PROBATION
SUPERVISION INCLUDING REPORTING
TO A PROBATION OFFICER. BEING
PART OF A PROBATION CASE LOW OR
HAVING TO FOLLOW PROBATION
CONDITIONS INCLUDING SEARCHES
AND JOKES AS- IT IS SOMETIMES
REFERRED TO AS VOLUNTARY
PROBATION BUT IN OUR
EXPERIENCE. IT IS BALLING. AND
AT. WE WILL SEND IT IN THESE
PARTIES INTO THOUSAND. THAT
YEAR TWENTY ONE THOUSAND YOU IN
LA ALONE REPORTING TO APPROACH
OFFICER OR TO APPROACH REFERRED
PROGRAM 81% FOR SCHOOL
ATTENDANCE FOR LOW GRADES
INSTEAD OF GETTING TUTORING OR
COUNSELING LA SPEND MORE MONEY
ON PROBATION OFFICERS I WENT TO
VENICE HIGH SCHOOL IN LOS
ANGELES I'VE NEVER BEEN A RATE
THE I WASN'T ON PROBATION BUT
PROBATION. IS TO STOP ME DALY
BASE. HE WARNED SUNGLASSES IN
WALKED OVER WITH THE- HE ONLY
BECAUSE ME BY MY LAST NAME. HE
WAS A MARTIN HERE ON MARCO YOUR
THE- YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO COME
SEEN I WAS NO I'M NOT ON
PROBATION HE WAS SAY YOU'RE ON
OUR ROSTER. MADE ME FEEL LIKE A
BAG AND I THINK IT MAY OTHER
PEOPLE IN MY SCHOOL SEEN EITHER
WAY. I STILL DON'T KNOW HOW I
GOT ON A LEASE WITH THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT I'D BE ME
SUPPORT. MY MOM WAS RAISED ME
AND MY LITTLE BROTHER BUYERS
SO. SHE GOT VERY STATE. PUT A
LOT OF PRESSURE ON ME TO DO
MORE HOME. ARE STARTING GIVEN
ANGRY AND FRUSTRATED MORE BUT
THE SCHOOL PROBATION OFFICER
NEVER OFFERED ME ANY COUNSELING
OR HELP WITH SCHOOL WORK. WHEN
I GOT INTO A FIGHT AT SCHOOL I
WAS EXPELLED AND I WAS REFERRED
TO ANOTHER SCHOOL. I WAS OUT OF
SCHOOL FOR ME. I WILL LEAVE
EVERY DAY FROM HOME JUST TO
MAKE IT LOOK LIKE I WAS IN
SCHOOL. I WAS REALLY IN THE
STREETS I DO NORMAL MOM SO I
WAS KICKED. OUT OF SCHOOL.
EVENTUALLY I'LL AND IN. SCHOOL
BUT THERE. WERE A TEACHER MADE
A RACIST. IN A LOS MUCH. IN TO
WHICH- I WAS. AND TAKE SINCE
JULY. HALL THE JUDGE TO ON
COURT ORDERED PRO. FOR THREE
YEARS ALL I GOT DURING THOSE
TWO YEARS REJECTED SEE. IF I
GOT IN COUNSELING OR TUTORING
I'M OFFERS HIGH SCHOOL INSTEAD
OF SO CALLED. VOLUNTARY
PROBATION SUPERVISION. MAYBE I
WOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN KICKED
OUT OF. SCHOOL OR RIGHT THE-
MAYBE I WOULDN'T HAVE A
CRIMINAL RECORD. IN HAVE YOU MY
SAME STORY WE NEED A NEW
CENTERS AND WE NEED COLLEGE PER.
AND STATE WE WERE PUT ON HOLD
VIOLENCE WOULD PUT ON VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM. SEARCH AND CALL. WE
ARE GETTING FOR THE AGREE.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING ME ARE
YOU TO VOTE YES ON A B. NOT
ONLY. SORRY WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR VERY POWERFUL TESTIMONY WE
ARE NOW GOING TO GO TO SUPPORT
HERE IN FORTY TWO OR THREE.
SEEING NONE. LET'S GO TO TWENTY
FORTY. AN LET'S GO TO OUR PHONE
LINES THOSE IN SUPPORT OF. AB
NINE OH ONE MADAM OPERATOR.
THANK YOU AND FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB NINE OH ONE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND OUR
FIRST CALL COMES FROM MINE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS CAITLYN
DURAN FROM THE ALLIANCE FOR
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR AT POLICY
LINK PROUD TO CO SPONSOR EIGHTY
NINE NO ONE. THANK YOU. AND
NINE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY
TURN MEMBERS BENJAMIN TREND
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND NINE NINETY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CANYON
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
IN MY NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALSO
QUICK TO USE JUSTICE COALITION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND NINE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
MORE COMMITTEE MEMBERS CAN
MCGILL WERE HONORED TO BE CO
SPONSORS FROM YOUTH JUSTICE
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND MINE EIGHTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING- THIS IS
EMILY ABOUT THE AND WITH YOU
JUST A COALITION OF CO SPONSOR.
ON SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND NINE
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MANY OF
THESE IN YOUR LEAGUE OF OMEN
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND NINE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS JOANNE TIPPIT FROM THE
LESSON FEDERAL LAW AND POVERTY
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND MY
NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU THIS
IS ALSO LOCALS WHAT THE EAST
BAY COMMUNITY LAW CENTER CROWD
COAST COSPONSORED IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND NINE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MIND
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BLIND SIXTY SEVEN BUT YOU YES.
MIRACLE OF MIRACLES IT WORKED
IS IT YOUR NAME IN THE LAST FOR
TWO HOURS. MY NAME IS STATE
YOUR NAME AND IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL PLEASE. WAS
THIS CONNIE LEIVA IT IS INDEED.
WE'VE ACTUALLY SET UP MIRACLE
OF MIRACLES AYE MA'AM ARE YOU
IN SUCH HURDLE WERE WORKING
AGAINST ME ARE YOU IN
SUPPORTERS CALLING ABOUT
EIGHTEEN I'M CALLING ABOUT AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE VERY.
EATING BOOTED OFF THE CALL
WE'RE SORRY ABOUT THAT WE WILL
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU MAN A
MODERATE YOU CAN CUT THAT LINE
OFF. OKAY ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE
OPEN VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AS MCGILL GIPSON WELL
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
OPPOSITION BUT THEN YOU WILL BE
HERE FOR ANY QUESTIONS AND
CLOSE ALL RIGHT I THINK OUR
LEAD OPPOSITION IS ERICA
HOFFMAN ERICA ARE YOU ON THE
LINE. YES I AM MADAM CHAIR
SHE'S ERICA HOFFMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION. FIRST OFF I WANT
TO THANK THE- THAT'S A MEMBER
GETS AND COMMITTEE STAFF. AND
THE SPONSORS OF THIS
LEGISLATION FOR THEIR
COLLABORATION AND WILLINGNESS
TO WORK WITH A NUMBER OF US YOU
HAVE MADE. HAD MAJOR CONCERNS
WITH THIS BILL- AS THE BILL IS
TO BE AMENDED THIS DOES ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS WITH REGARDS THE
IMPLICATIONS I'M SORRY. AND
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES ON
STUDENTS AND ON OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT SCHOOLS PROVIDE- I'VE ON
BEHALF OF THE SB A WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE TO BE
ADOPTED ON THE SENATE FLOOR.
WILL WE MOVE OUR OPPOSITION
BELT. SO EVERYBODY AGAIN. AND
THAT'S IT EXCELLENT THANK YOU
SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT WE WANT TO
OPPOSITION HERE AND ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE LET'S MOVE TO
TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NONE LET'S
MOVE TO OUR TELEPHONE LINES
MADAME MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO IS IN
OPPOSITION AB EIGHT NINE OH ONE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF AB NINE A ONE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN A
FEW MOMENTS PLEASE. AND LINE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS OTHERS WITH THE
ANA KELLY ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE FOR CURRENTLY
OPPOSE THE BILL DUE TO SOME
TECHNICAL LANGUAGE ISSUES BUT
WE'RE HOPING TO REMEMBER
OPPOSITION STAN- WE HAVE HAD
COME PROACTIVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE.
INCLUDING A CO SPONSOR THEM ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO HAVING A
NEUTRAL POSITION. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND NINE EIGHTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN I HAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS DANIEL SANCHEZ
WITH THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS I WANT ALSO EXTEND OUR
APPRECIATION FOR OUR WORK
TOGETHER WITH THE AUTHOR ON.
THIS YOUR GOLDEN PROVIDING YOU
VERY IMPORTANT TERMS TO THE
COURTS TO ARE USED ON BASED ON
SOME OF THE RECENT AMENDMENTS
ON WHICH TO ADDRESS MANY OF OUR
CONCERNS I'M- APPRECIATIVE OF
THAT WE GET RECORD. AT THE ON
GOING DISCUSSION. AND
FORTHCOMING AMEND. SO I WE LOOK
FORWARD TO A- THOSE FURTHER A
THE HOPES OF OUR- THE
OPPOSITION IN THE KIND DAYS.
THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU THE
WITNESS. AND NINE FORTY SIX
LINE IS A PLEASE AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JEFF
BACA REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY TO OF SCHOOLS UNLIKE THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS WE ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION UPON REVIEW OF THE
FORTHCOMING AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU. NEXT
BAKER. AND NINE SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY SIXTY SEVEN. THIS IS
YOU YEAH YOUR OPEN I'M BACK ON
AGAIN BUT I'M STILL WANTING TO
TALK ABOUT NINETEEN EIGHTY OF
THE OTHER ONE I'M NOT SURE WHY
I'M ON HERE RIGHT NOW YET
YOU'RE ON THE WRONG LINE MA'AM
THIS IS OUR LAST BILL OF THE
DAY SO THANK YOU VERY. MUCH
MADAME MODERATOR PLEASE AND I
NINETY ONE IN IN. MY NINETY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THANK YOU ANDREA
BALL ON THE HOUSE THE ORANGE
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
ONE ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS. AT ALL THE
WORK ON THE BILL LOOK FOR
PAYING THE BILL WITH THE
AMENDMENTS AND REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION. THE MATCH THANK YOU.
TEN NINE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR THIS IS MICHAEL SAYS
THERE WITH THE KERN COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
OFFICE AS NOTED ON PAGE NINE OF
THIRTY COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. WE
BELIEVE WE'VE REACHED AN
AGREEMENT- TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE AMENDMENTS I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE CARE STAFF
THE SPOT. AND THE AUTHOR THEIR
WORK WITH US ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION OF AB NINE A ONE
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
MODERATOR BUT WE'RE GOING TO
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANYWAY MANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
OR CONCERNS. DOCTOR PAN THANK
YOU AND- THE REDUCE AND A WHAT
THANK YOU FOR THE BILL THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PERCENT
YOUR BILL FOR YOU ARE YOU
HEADING OVER HERE AND- SO NEW
AND ORDER OF- THE BILL IS
YOU'RE GOING TO BE- WORKING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE THOSE
FINAL MOMENTS ON THE FLOOR I
JUST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
SIR MY KNEE AND- MOST WERE
NATIONALLY IF TO THE PREVIOUS
VERSION I DO I RECOGNIZE THAT
SACRAMENTO COUNTY THAT THEY
THEY'VE DONE SOME EXCELLENT
WORK AND SUPPORTING USE SO
CERTAINLY THAT WAS NOT THE
ISSUE- FROM POINT OF VIEW BUT I
ALSO APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT
YOUR POINT OF VIEW THAT WE
SHOULDN'T TAP A USE TO- OUR END
QUOTE VOLUNTARY. DOESN'T ONLY
APPROBATION YOU KNOW THERE ARE
MANY EXCELLENT PROBATION
OFFICERS AND LEADERS WHO WHO DO
GOOD WORK AND SUPPORTING USE-
DOES KERRY A HYPOTHESIS. AND
THEN ISSUE AROUND BEING PART OF
THE WELL JUST SYSTEM MIDDLE
COMMIT A CRIME SO THAT CAN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
STAKEHOLDERS. THIS IS AND THAT
WOULD BE PLEASE TO MOVE THE
BUILT TIME. THANK YOU SO PAN ON
OF IS MISTER US GLOW. CENTER
GLAZER. THANK YOU- CHAIR LEYVA-
I WOULD I WOULD KNOW TO AS THE
EARLIER SPEAKER FROM ALAMEDA
COUNTY FROM MY DISTRICT THAT.
THERE ARE SOME SOME SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAMS TO HELP WITH THE
CHRONICALLY TRUANT TEENS AND I
GUESS IT'S TRYING TO FIND THE
RIGHT BALANCE. HI BUT IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY. DISTRICT
ATTORNEY REPORTS THAT. 2% OF
THE TEENS THAT GO THROUGH THEIR
MEDIATION PROGRAM. BAKER
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN BOTH
SCHOOL ATTENDANCE AS WELL AS
SOME OF THE UNDERLYING ISSUES
THAT AFFECTED THAT ATTENDANCE-
I APPRECIATE THE- THE AUTHORS-
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THAT
ALAMEDA COUNTY. AND OTHER. I
NOT A C. PRIVY TO THE THAT.
HAVE BEEN NOT REFERENCED IN THE
COURSE OF THIS. HEARING BUT I
GUESS I'D BE INTERESTED IN
HEARING THE AUTHOR. SPEAK TO A
IN HIS. DESIRE WILLINGNESS OR
NOT TO. WORK WITH THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OF ALLEGHENY COUNTY
AND IN TERMS OF THE MANDATORY
VERSUS VOLUNTARY PROGRAMS THAT
THEY TO UNDERTAKE. THANK YOU
CENTER GLAZER US ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GIPSON CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT IN
YOUR CLOTHES YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
PERFECT PLACE FOR SEAT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATORS THINK
THE CHAIR- FOR- KEEPING IT OPEN
FOR ME SO I GOT HERE AND ALSO I
THINK SENATOR PAN FOR
PRESENTING THE BILL ON MY
BEHALF I WANT ALL THANK THE
TESTIMONY OF MISS THOMAS WAS A
COMPELLING TESTIMONY WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE- ALL. OF
BY TO SUPPORT WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS FOR OVER A YEAR.
TO GET US TO THE POINT. AND
THAT'S A LABOR INTO TO BUT
CERTAIN WAS WELL WERE IT TO TRY
OF STRAW THE BASS. WE BELIEVE
THAT OUR NEW OF MEDS IT WILL BE
TAKE THE SENATE IS RIGHT ABOUT
BALLOTS. WITH. DATE WERE NOT
PENALIZE IN SUCH A WAY UNDER A
VOLUNTARY PROBATION AND THOSE
ARE THE THINGS THAT WERE PLAYED
BY.HAND THAT WAS OUT. BY
TESTING. WE BELIEVE THERE ARE
GOOD PROGRAMS OUT THERE AND
THIS PROVIDES A BALLOT SO THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK IN THE WHO
ARE WHO NEED TO BE IN A PROGRAM
WOULD BE IN A PROGRAM OF THOSE
WHO SHOULD NOT BE A PROGRAM. AS
THOMAS CHECK IT LATER- SHE
BROKE BROKE SHE WAS NEVER ON
PROBATION BUT YET STILL SHE WAS
TREATED AS IF SO AND THEN BACK
CALLS KNOWLEDGE FROM BUT ALSO
SOME OF HER BE FOR THE ACTED
OUT. DRIVE WITH IT. PAST THAT
BUT WE TO HAVE TO. IN SCHOOL
AND WE WILL CAN. TO WORK WE
BEST IN THOSE FROM THE HIS
ATTORNEY OFFICES SINCE. START
WE- THAT WE HAVE NINETY NINE
PERCENT. OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION
BECAUSE WE HAVE MOVED THE
NEEDLE TO A BALLOTS- APPROACH
AND STARS. YES FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON ON A. B. NINE OH ONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YU
SIMPLY MEMBER GIPSON THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR PAN.
AND THE- THE MOTION IS THAT THE
MEASURE BE RETURNED TO. FOUR
FOUR CONSIDERING. BETTER INSULT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ITEM
TWELVE EIGHTEEN ZERO. THE MOST.
IS THA THE BE RETURNED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR FOR CONSIDERATION
SENATOR LATE HI. HI WILK.
CHIANG DORADO I. RUSSELL I.
GLAZER. BUT AS CENTER GLAZER
NOT VOTING AT THE CURRENT
MOMENT. THESE ARE NOT VOTING
MCGUIRE PAN HI HAN I. ALL RIGHT
WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN AND
HAVE SENATOR MCGUIRE COME BACK
AND THEY WILL BE ABLE TO CLOSE
THE ROLE THANK YOU FOR MEMBERS
GIPSON. I JUST TEXTED.
OKAY.
WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP OUR ON CALL
BILLS WHICH IS AB NINE A ONE
MAN CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON AB
NINE OH ONE. ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
AB NINE ZERO ONE THE MOTION IS
THAT THE MEASURE BE RETURNED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR FOR
CONSIDERATION. CHAIR VOTING ALL
BY WILK. CHIANG GLAZER. YOU'RE
STILL ON MUTE. STUCK IN HERE ME
WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW YES I
TECHNOLOGY AND IT'S JOHN YOU'RE
GOOD EDITOR GLAZER AT ALL CAST
OCCURS YOU VOTE AYE THANK YOU
SIR MUCH APPRECIATED THAT BILL
IS OUT FOUR ZERO. THE FINISH
COLLEGE. A MAN CONSULTANT
PLEASE FINISH CALLING. CENTER
GLAZER ALLY HIGHER BUT BILLS
OUT FOUR ZERO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU'RE NOT
ABLE. TO TESTIMONY PLUTO
TESTIFY PLEASE THE YOUR OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
WE WANT TO INCLUDE TESTIMONY IN
THE OFFICIAL DURING RECORDS
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION I PERSONALLY
WOULD JUST TO THANK OUR I. T.
THE WAY THIS INCREDIBLY SO
BLESSED THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND EVERYONE ELSE
CHANGED AT ADOPTED